the following is a conversation with
kevin systrom co-founder and long-time
ceo of instagram including for six years
after facebook's acquisition of
instagram
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description
and now here's my conversation with
kevin
systrom
at the risk of uh asking the rolling
stones to play satisfaction let me ask
you about the origin story of instagram
sure
so maybe some context you
like we were talking about offline grew
up in massachusetts
learned computer programming there liked
to play doom two
uh worked at a vinyl record store then
you went to stanford
turned down mr uh
mark zuckerberg and facebook
went to florence to study photography
those are just some random beautiful
impossibly brief glimpses into a life so
let me ask again can you take me through
the origin story of instagram giving
that context you basically set it up um
all right so uh we have a fair amount of
time so i'll go into some detail but
basically what i'll say is
um
instagram started out of a company
actually called bourbon
and it was spelled b-u-r-b-n
and uh
a couple things were happening at the
time so if we zoom back to 2010 not a
lot of people remember what was
happening in the dot-com world then uh
but
check-in apps were all the rage
so what's this checking out uh gowalla
four square hot potato
so i'm at a place i'm gonna tell the
world that i'm at this place that's
right what's what's the idea behind this
kind of app by the way you know what i'm
gonna answer that but through
what instagram became and why i believe
instagram replaced them
so the whole idea was to share with the
world what you were doing specifically
with your friends right
um
but they were all the rage and
foursquare was getting all the press and
i remember sitting around saying hey i
want to build something but i don't know
what i want to build what if i built a
better
version of foursquare
and i asked myself
why don't i like foursquare or how could
it be improved
um
and basically i sat down and i said i
think that if you have a few extra
features it might be enough one of which
happened to be posting a photo of where
you were
there were some others it turns out that
wasn't enough my co-founder joined we
were going to attack uh you know
foursquare and the likes and and try to
build something interesting
um and no one used it no one cared
because it wasn't enough it wasn't it
wasn't different enough right
so one day we were sitting down and we
asked ourselves okay let's come to jesus
moment
are we going to do this startup
and if we're going to we can't do what
we're currently doing we have to switch
it up so what do people love the most so
we sat down and we wrote out
three things that we thought people
uniquely loved about our product that
weren't in other products
photos happened to be the top one so
sharing a photo of what you were doing
where you were at the moment was not
something
products let you do really facebook was
like post an album of your vacation from
two weeks ago right twitter allowed you
to post a photo but their feed was
primarily text and they didn't show the
photo in line or at least i don't think
they did at the time
so
even though it seems totally
stupid and obvious to us now at the
moment then
posting a photo of what you were doing
at the moment was like not a thing
so
we decided to go after that because we
noticed that people who used our service
the one thing they happened to like the
most was posting a photo
so that was the beginning of instagram
and yes like we went through and we
added filters and there's a bunch of
stories around that but the origin of
this was that we were trying to be a
checking app realized that no one wanted
another checking app
it became a photo sharing app but one
that was much more about what you're
doing and where you are
and that's why when i say i think we've
replaced checkin apps
it became a check-in via a photo rather
than
saying your location and then optionally
adding a photo when you were thinking
about what people like
from where did you get a sense that this
is what people like you you said we sat
down we wrote some stuff down on paper
where is that intuition that seems
fundamental to the success
of
an app like instagram what is that idea
where's that list of three things come
from exactly
only after having studied machine
learning now for a couple of years
i like i have a you have understood
yourself
i've started to make connections like we
can go into this later but
obviously the the um
the connections between
machine learning and the human brain i
think are stretched sometimes right
at the same time
being able to backprop and being able to
like look at the world try something
figure out how you're wrong how wrong
you are
and then nudge your company in the right
direction
based on how wrong you are is like a
fascinating concept right and i don't we
didn't know we were doing it at the time
but that's basically what we were doing
right
we put it out to call it a hundred
people
and you would look at their data you
would say what are they sharing
what like what resonates what doesn't
resonate we think they're going to
resonate with x but turns out they
resonate with y
okay shift the company towards y
and it turns out if you do that enough
quickly enough you can get to a solution
that has product market fit most
companies fail
because they sit there and they don't
either their learning rate's too slow
they sit there and they're just they're
adamant that they're right even though
the data is telling them they're not
right
or
they their learning rate's too high and
they wildly chase different ideas and
they never actually set on on one where
where they don't groove right and i
think when we sat down and we wrote out
those three ideas what we were saying is
what are the three possible
whether they're local or global maxima
in our world right
that users are telling us they like
because they're using the product that
way
it was clear people liked the photos
because that was the thing they were
doing
and we just said okay like what if we
just cut out most of the other stuff and
focus on that thing
um and then it happened to be a
multi-billion dollar business and
it's that easy by the way yeah i guess
so um well nobody ever writes about
neural networks that
miserably failed so this this particular
neural network succeeded this is the
sound all the time right yeah but nobody
right default state is failing yes
um when you said the way people are
using the app
is that the lost function for this
neural network or is it also self-report
like do you ever ask people what they
like or do you have to
track exactly what they're doing not
what they're saying
i once made a thanksgiving dinner okay
and
uh it was for
relatives and i like to cook a lot okay
and i worked really hard on picking the
specific
uh dishes and
and i was really proud because i had
planned it out using a gantt chart and
like it was ready on time and everything
was hot nice like i don't know if you're
a big thanksgiving guy but like the
worst thing about thanksgiving
is when the turkey is cold and some
things are hot and something anyway you
got a gantt chart you actually have a
chart oh yeah yeah omni plan fairly
expensive like gantt chart thing that i
think maybe 10 people have purchased
in the world but i'm one of them and i
use it for recipe planning only around
big holidays that's brilliant by the way
do people do this kind of uh over
engineering it's not overdue it's just
engineering it's planning thanksgiving
is a complicated uh
set of events with some uncertainty with
a lot of things going on you should be
able you should be planning in this way
there should be a chart it's not over i
mean so what's funny is um
brief aside yes uh brilliant i love
cooking i love food i love coffee and
i've spent some time with some chefs who
like know their stuff and
they always just take out a piece of
paper and just work backwards in rough
order like it's never perfect but rough
order it's just like oh that makes sense
why not just work backwards from from
the end goal right and put in some
buffer time and
so i probably overspecified it a bit
using a gantt chart but the fact that
you can do it it's what professional
kitchens roughly do
they just don't call it a gantt chart or
at least i don't think they do um anyway
i was telling a story about thanksgiving
so here's uh here's the thing
i'm sitting down we have the meal and
then i'm
you know i got to know ray dalio
fairly well over maybe the last year of
instagram um
and one thing that he kept saying was
like feedback is really hard to get
honestly from people
and i sat down at
after dinner i said guys i want feedback
what was good and what was bad yes and
what's funny is like literally everyone
just said everything was great
and i like personally knew i had screwed
up a handful of things
um but no one would say it
and can you imagine now
not something as high stakes as
thanksgiving dinner okay thanksgiving
dinner it's not that high stakes
but you're trying to build a product and
everyone knows you left your job for it
you're trying to build it out and you're
trying to make something wonderful
and it's yours right you designed it
now try asking for feedback
and know that you're giving this to your
friends and your family
people have trouble giving hard feedback
people have trouble saying
i don't like this or this isn't great or
this is how it's failed me
in fact
um
you usually have two classes of people
people who just won't say bad things you
can literally say to them please tell me
what you hate most about this and they
won't do it they'll try but they won't
and then the other class of people are
just negative period about everything
and it's hard to parse out
like what is true and what isn't
so my rule of thumb with this
is you should always ask people
but at the end of the day it's amazing
what data will tell you
and that's why with whatever project i
work on even now
collecting data from the beginning on
usage patterns so engagement how many
days of the week do they use it
how many i don't know if we were to go
back to instagram how many impressions
per day
right is that growing is that shrinking
and don't be like overly
scientific about it right because maybe
you have 50 beta users or something
but what's fascinating is that
data doesn't lie
people are very
uh defensive about their time
they'll say oh i'm so busy i'm sorry i
didn't get to use the app like i'm just
you know um
but i don't know you're posting on
instagram the whole time
so
i don't know at the end of the day like
at facebook there was
you know before time spent became
kind of this loaded
term there
the idea that people
people's currency in their lives is time
and they only have a certain amount of
time to give things whether it's friends
or family or apps or tv shows or
whatever it's
there's no way of inventing more of it
at least not that i know of
if they don't use it it's because it's
not great
so
the moral of the story is you can ask
all you want but you just have to look
at the data
and
data doesn't lie right i mean there's
metrics there's uh
data can obscure the key insight if
you're not careful so
so time spent in the app that's ones
there's so many metrics you can put at
this and they will give you totally
different insights
especially when you're trying to create
something that doesn't obviously exist
yet
so
you know
measuring maybe
why you left the app or measuring
special moments
of happiness that will make sure you
return to the app or moments of
happiness that are long lasting versus
like dopamine short term
all of those things but i think i
suppose in the beginning
you can just get away with just asking
the question
which features are used a lot let's do
more of that
and how hard was the decision
and uh i mean maybe you can tell me what
instagram looked in the beginning but
how hard was it to make
pictures the first class citizen that's
a revolutionary idea
like um at whatever point instagram
became this feed
of
photos
that's quite brilliant
plus
i also don't know when this happened but
they're all shaped the same
it's like uh i have to tell you why
that's the interesting part
why is that so a couple of things one is
data data like you're right you can over
interpret data like imagine trying to
fly a plane
by staring at
i don't know a single metric like
airspeed
you don't know if you're going up or
down i mean it correlates with up or
down but you don't actually know it will
never help you land the plane
so don't stare at one metric like it
turns out you have to synthesize a bunch
of metrics to know where to go
um but it doesn't lie like if your air
speed is zero unless it's not working
right if if it's zero
you're probably going to fall out of the
sky so
generally you look around and you have
the scan going yes
and you're just asking yourself is this
working or is this not working
um
but people have trouble explaining
how they actually feel
so just it's about synthesizing both of
them so then instagram right uh we were
talking about revolutionary moment where
where the feed became
square photos basically and photos first
and then square footage yeah um
it was clear to me that the biggest so
i believe the biggest companies are
founded
when
enormous technical shifts happen and the
biggest technical shift that happened
right before instagram was founded was
the advent of a phone that didn't suck
the iphone right like in retrospect
we're like oh my god the first iphone
that almost had
like it wasn't that good
but compared to everything else at the
time it was
amazing
and by the way the first
phone that had an incredible camera
that could that could like do as well as
the point and shoot you might carry
around
was the iphone 4 and that was right when
instagram launched and we looked around
and we said what will change because
everyone has a camera in their pocket
and it was so clear to me that the the
world of
social networks before
it was based in the desktop and sitting
there and having a link you could share
right
and that wasn't going to be the case so
the question is what would you share if
you were out and about in the world
if not only did you have a camera that's
in your pocket but by the way that
camera had a network attached to it that
allowed you to share instantly
that seemed revolutionary and a bunch of
people saw it at the same time it wasn't
just instagram there were a bunch of
competitors
the thing we did
i think was not only well we focused on
two things so we wrote down those things
we circled photos and we said i think we
should invest in this
but then we said what sucks about photos
one they look like crap right they just
at least back then now
my phone takes pretty great photos right
um back then they were blurry not so
great compressed right
two
uh it was really slow
like really slow to upload a photo
and i'll tell a fun story about that and
explain to you why they're all the same
size and square as well
um and three
man if you wanted to share a photo on
different networks you had to go to each
of the individual apps and select all of
them and upload individually and
so we're like all right those are the
pain points we're gonna focus on that so
one instead of
because they weren't beautiful um we
were like why don't we lean into the
fact that they're not beautiful and i
remember studying in florence my
photography teacher gave me this whole
gay camera and i'm not sure everyone
knows what a whole gay camera is but
they're these old-school plastic cameras
i think they're produced in china at the
time
and they're i want to say the original
ones like from the 70s or the 80s or
something they're supposed to be like
three dollar cameras for the every
person
they took nice medium format films large
large
negatives
but they kind of blurred the the the
light and they kind of like light leaked
into the side and there was this whole
resurgence where people looked at that
and said oh my god this is a style right
and i remember using that in florence
and just saying well why don't we just
like lean into the fact that these
photos suck and make them suck more
but in an artistic way
and it turns out that had product market
fit people really liked that they were
willing to share their not so great
photos if they
looked
not so great on purpose okay
it's the second part
that's the where the filters come into
the picture yeah so computational
modification of photos to make them look
extra crappy to where it becomes art
yeah yeah and
i mean
add light leaks add like an overlay
filter make them more contrasty than
they should be uh the first
filter we ever produced was called x-pro
2. and i designed it while i was in this
small little bed and breakfast room in
total santos mexico i was trying to take
a break from the
the bourbon days and i i remember saying
to my co-founder i just need like a week
to reset
and that was
on that trip worked on the first filter
because i said you know i think i can do
this and i literally iterated
one by one over the rgb values in the
array that was the photo
and just slightly shifted basically
there was a function of our function of
g function of b
that just shifted them slightly it
wasn't rocket science um and it turns
out that actually made your photo look
pretty cool
it just mapped from one color space to
another color space
it was simple but it was really slow i
mean if you applied a filter
i think it used to take two or three
seconds to render
only eventually would i figure out how
to do it on the gpu and i'm not even
sure it was gpu but was using opengl but
anyway um i would eventually figure that
out and then it would be instant but it
used to be really slow by the way anyone
who's watching or listening
it's amazing what you can get away with
in a startup as long as the product
outcome is right for the user like you
can be slow you can be terrible you can
be
as long as you have product market fit
people will put up with a lot and then
the question is just about compressing
making it more performant over time so
that they get that product market fit
instantly
so fascinating because there's some
things where
those three seconds would
make or break the app
but some things you're saying not it's
hard to know when you know it's what
it's the problem spotify solved
making streaming like
work
and
like delays in listening to music is a
huge negative
even like slight delays
but here you're saying i mean how do you
know
when those three seconds are okay are
you just gonna have to
try it out because to me my intuition
would be
those three seconds would kill the app
like i would try to do the opengl thing
right
so i wish i were that smart at the time
um
i wasn't i just knew how to do what i
knew how to do right
and i decided okay like why don't i just
iterate over the values and change them
and what's interesting
is that um
compared to the alternatives no one else
used opengl
right so everyone else was doing that
the dumb way and in fact they were doing
it at a high resolution now comes in the
small resolution that we'll talk about
for a second
um
by choosing 512 pixels by 512 pixels
which i believe it was at the time
we iterated over a lot fewer pixels than
our competitors who were trying to do
these enormous output like images yeah
so instead of taking 20 seconds i mean
three seconds feels pretty good right
so on a relative basis we were winning
like a lot
okay so that's answer number one answer
number two is uh
we actually focused on latency in the
right places so we did this really
wonderful thing um
when you uploaded so uh the way it would
work is you know you'd take your phone
you'd take the photo and then you'd go
to the um
you'd go the edit screen where you would
caption it
and on that caption screen you start
typing you think okay like what's a
clever caption and and i said to mike
hey when i worked on the gmail team you
know what they did when you typed in
your username or your email address
even before you've entered in your
password like the chat probability once
you enter in your username that you're
going to actually sign in is extremely
high
so why not just start loading your
account in the background not not like
sending it down to the desktop that
would be a security uh uh
issue but like load it into memory on
the server like get it ready prepare it
i always thought that was so fascinating
and unintuitive i was like mike why
don't we just do that but like we'll
just upload the photo and like assume
you're gonna upload the photo and if you
don't
forget about it we'll delete it right
so what ended up happening
was people would caption their uh photo
they'd press done or upload
and you'd see this little progress bar
just go
it was lightning fast okay
we were no faster than anyone else at
the time but by choosing 512 by 512 and
doing in the background it almost
guaranteed that it was done by the time
you captioned
and everyone when they used it was like
how the hell is this thing so fast
but we were slow we just hid the the
slowness it wasn't like
these things are just like it's a shelly
game you're just hiding the latency
that
that mattered to people like a lot and i
think that so you were willing to put up
with a slow filter if it meant you could
share it immediately and of course we
added sharing options which let you
distribute it really quickly that was
the third part
um
so latency matters but relative to what
and then
there's some like tricks you can get
around to just hiding the latency um
like i don't know if spotify starts
downloading the next song eagerly i'm
assuming they do
there are a bunch of ideas here that are
not rocket science that
that really help
and all of that was
stuff you were explicitly having a
discussion about like
those designs and argument you were
having like arguments discussions
uh i'm sure it was arguments i mean
i'm not sure if you've met my co-founder
mike but he's a pretty nice guy and he's
very reasonable and uh
and we both just saw eye to eye and
we're like yeah just like
make this fast early seem fast
it'll be great i mean honestly i think
the most contentious thing and he would
say this too initially
was um i was on an iphone 3g so like the
the not so fast one and he had a brand
new iphone 4. i was cheap nice um
and his feed loaded super smoothly like
when he would scroll from photo to photo
buttery smooth right but on my phone
every time you got to a new photo it was
like
a chunk allocate memory like all this
stuff right
i was like mike that's unacceptable he's
like oh come on man just like upgrade
your phone basically you didn't actually
say that it's nicer than that um
but i could tell he wished like i would
just stop being cheap and just get a new
phone
but what's funny is we actually sat
there working on that little detail for
a few days before launch and
that polished experience plus the fact
that uploading seemed fast for all these
people who didn't have nice phones
i think meant a lot
because
far too often you see teams focus not on
performance
they focus on
what's the cool computer science problem
they can solve
right can we scale this thing to a
billion users and they've got like 100
right
yeah
you talked about loss function so i want
to come back to that
but like the loss function is like do
you provide a great happy magical
whatever experience for the consumer
and listen if it happens to involve
something complex and technical then
great
but it turns out i think most of the
time
those experiences are just sitting there
waiting to be built with like not that
complex solutions
uh but everyone is just like so stuck in
their own head that they have to over
engineer everything and then they forget
about the easy stuff
i mean also maybe to flip the lost
function there is you're trying to
minimize the number of times
you there's unpleasant experience right
like uh the one you mention where when
you go to the next photo it freezes for
a little bit so it's almost as opposed
to maximizing pleasure it's probably
easier to minimize
the number of like
the friction
yeah and as we all know you just you
just uh you just make the pleasure
negative and then minimize everything so
we're mapping this all back to neural
networks but actually can i say one
thing on that which is
i don't know a lot about machine
learning but i feel like i've i've tried
studying a bunch that whole idea of
reinforcement learning
and planning out more than the greedy
single experience i think is
is the closest you can get to
like ideal product design thinking
where you're not saying hey like can we
have a great experience just this one
time
but like what is the right way to
onboard someone what series of
experiences correlate most with them
hanging on long term right so not just
saying oh did the photo load slowly a
couple times or did they get a great
photo at the top of their feed
but like what are the things that are
going to make this person come back
over the next week over the next month
and as a product designer asking
yourself okay i want to optimize not
just minimize bad experiences in the
short run but like
how do i get someone to engage over the
next month
and i'm not going to claim at all that i
thought that way at all at the time
because i certainly didn't but if i were
going back and giving myself any advice
it would be thinking what are those what
are those second order effects that you
can create
and it turns out having your friends on
the service
it's an enormous win so starting with a
very small group of people that produce
content that you wanted to see which we
did we seeded the community very well i
think
ended up mattering and
so
yeah you said that community is one of
the most important things so it's from a
metrics perspective from uh maybe a
philosophy perspective
building a certain kind of community
within the app see i wasn't sure what
exactly you meant by that when when i've
heard you say that maybe you can
elaborate but as i understand now it's
can literally mean
get your friends onto the app
yeah
think of it this way
you can build an amazing restaurant or
bar or whatever right
but if you show up and you're the only
one there is it like does it matter how
good the food is
the drinks whatever um no um these are
inherently social experiences that we
were working on
so
the idea of having people there
like you needed to have that otherwise
it was just to filter out but by the way
part of the genius
i'm going to say genius even though i
wasn't really genius was starting to be
marauding as a filter app
was awesome
the fact that you could so we talk about
single player mode a lot which is like
can you play the game alone
and instagram you could totally play
alone you could filter your photos and a
lot of people would tell me i didn't
even realize that this thing was a
social network
until my friend showed up it totally
worked as a single player
game and then when your friend showed up
all of a sudden it was like oh
not only was this great alone but now i
actually have this trove of photos that
people can look at and start liking and
then i can like theirs and
so it was this bootstrap method of how
do you make the thing not suck when the
restaurant is empty
yeah but the thing is when you say
friends i mean we're not necessarily
referring to friends in the physical
space so you're not bringing your
physical friends with you you're also
making new friends so you're finding new
community so it's not immediately
obvious to me that
it's like it's almost like building any
kind of community
it was it was both and what we learned
very early on was what made instagram
special and the reason why you would
sign up for it versus say just sit on
facebook and look at your friends photos
of course we were live and of course it
was interesting to see what your friends
were doing now
but the fact that you could connect with
people who like took really beautiful
photos in a certain style all around the
world whether they were travelers it was
the beginning or beginning of the
influencer economy there's these people
who became professional instagramers way
back when right
um
but they took these amazing photos and
some of them were photographers right um
like professionally
and all of a sudden you had this moment
in the day when you could open up this
app and sure you could see what your
friends were doing but also it was like
oh my god that's a beautiful beautiful
waterfall or oh my god i didn't realize
there was that corner of england or like
really cool stuff
um
and the beauty about instagram early on
was that it was
international by default you didn't have
to speak english to use it right you
could just look at the photos
worked great
we did translate we had some pretty bad
translations but we did translate the
app
and uh
you know even if our translations were
pretty poor the the idea that you could
just connect with other people through
their images was pretty powerful
how much uh technical difficulties there
with the programming like what
programming language you were talking
about what was zero i'd like maybe it
was hard for us but um i mean we
there was nothing the only thing that
was complex about instagram at the
beginning
technically was making it scale and we
were
just plain old objective c for the
client uh so it was iphone only
yep as an android person i'm deeply
offended but go ahead again come on this
was 2010. oh sure sure sorry android's
getting a lot better yeah yeah so
um i take it back you're right if i were
to do something today i think it would
be very different in terms of launch
strategy right android's enormous too uh
but anyway um back to that moment it was
objective c uh and then
we were python based uh which is just
like this is before python was really
cool like now it's cool because it's all
these machine learning libraries like
support python and right
now it's super
now it's like cool to be by the back
then it was like oh google uses python
like maybe you should use python
facebook was php like
i had worked at a small startup of some
ex-googlers that used python so we used
it and we used a framework called django
uh still exists and people use for
basically
the back end and then you threw a couple
interesting things in there i mean we
used postgres which was kind of fun it
was a little bit like hipster database
at the time right
my sequel my sequel like everyone used
my sequel so like using postcards was
like an interesting decision right uh
but we used it because it had a bunch of
uh geo features built in because we
thought we were going to be a checking
out pretty much it's also super cool now
so you were into python before it was
cool and you were into postgres before
it was cool yeah we were basically like
not only hipster
hipster photo company hipster tech
company right uh we also adopted redis
early and like loved it i mean it solved
so many problems for us
and turns out that's still pretty cool
but the programming was very easy it was
like sign up a user have a feed there
was nothing
no machine learning at all zero can you
get some context how many users at each
of these stages are we talking about 100
users a thousand users so the stage i
just described i mean that technical
stack lasted through
probably 50 million users
um
i mean seriously like you can get away
with a lot with with a pretty basic
stack um like i think a lot of startups
try to over engineer their solutions
from the beginning to like really scale
and you can get away with a lot
that being said most of the first two
years of instagram was literally just
trying to make that stack scale and it
wasn't it was it was not a python
problem it was like
literally just like where do we put the
data like it's all coming in too fast
like how do we store it how do we make
sure to be up how do we like
how do we make sure we're on the right
side of boxes that they have enough
memory um those were the issues but can
you speak to the choices you make at
that stage when you're growing so
quickly
do you use something like somebody
else's computer infrastructure or do you
build in-house
i'm only laughing because we when we
launched we had a single
computer that we had rented
in some colo space in la i don't even
remember what it was called
because i thought that's what you did
when i worked at a company called odio
that became twitter i remember visiting
our space in san francisco you walked in
you had to wear the ear things and it
was
cold and fans everywhere right
and we had to you know plug one out
replace one and i was the intern so i
just like held things
but i thought to myself oh this is how
it goes and then i remember being in a
vc's office
i think it was benchmark's office and i
think we ran into another entrepreneur
and they were like oh how are things
going we're like uh you know trying to
scale this thing
and they were like well i mean can't you
just add more instances and i was like
what do you mean
and they're like instances on amazon i
was like what are those
and it was this moment where we realized
how deep in it we were because we had no
idea that aw aws existed nor should we
be using it anyway
that night we went back to the office
and we got on aws but we we did this
really dumb thing we're
i'm so sorry to people listening but um
we brought up an instance which was our
our database it's going to be a
replacement for our database
but we had it talking over the public
internet to our little box in la that
was our app server very nice yeah um
that's how sophisticated we were and
obviously that was very very slow
didn't work at all i mean it worked but
didn't work did we only like later that
night did we realize we had to have it
all together
but at least like if you're listening
right now and you're thinking you know i
have no chance i'm going to start to
start i have no chance
i don't know we did it and we made a
bunch of really dumb mistakes initially
i think the question is how quickly do
you learn that you're making a mistake
and do you do the right thing
immediately right after so you didn't
pay for those mistakes by you know by
failure so
yeah how quickly did you fix it
i guess there's a lot of ways to sneak
up to this question of how the hell do
you scale the thing
other startups if you have an idea how
do you scale the thing is this is just
aws
and uh
you try to write the kind of code that's
easy to spread across a large number of
instances and then
the rest is just put money into it
basically i would say a couple things
first off
don't even ask the question just find
product market fit
duct tape it together right like if you
have to i think there's a big caveat
here which i want to get to
but generally all that matters is
product market fit that's all that
matters if people like your product
do not worry about when 50 000 people
use your product because you will be
happy that you have that problem when
you get there i actually can't name
many
startups
where they go from
nothing to something overnight and they
can't figure out how to scale it there
are some
but i think nowadays it's a when i say a
solved problem like
there are ways of solving it
the base case is typically that startups
worry way too much about
scaling way too early and forget that
they actually have to make something
that people like that's the that's the
default mistake case
but what i'll say is um
once you start scaling
i mean hiring quickly people who have
seen the game before and just know how
to do it it it becomes um
it becomes a bit of like yeah just throw
instances of the problem right
but the last thing i'll say on this that
i think did save us um
we were pretty rigorous about writing
tests uh from the beginning
that helped us
move very very quickly when we wanted to
rewrite parts of the product
and know that we weren't breaking
something else
tests are one of those things where it's
like you go slow to go fast
and they suck when you have to write
them because you have to figure it out
and
they're always those ones that break
when you don't want them to break and
they're annoying and it feels like you
spent all this time but
looking back i think that like long-term
optimal even with the team of four
it allowed us to move very very quickly
because anyone could touch any part of
the the the product and know that they
weren't going to bring down the site or
at least in general at which point do
you know product market fit how many
users would you say what is it all it
takes is like 10 people or is it a
thousand is it 50 000
i don't think it is
generally a question of absolute numbers
i think it's a question of cohorts and i
think it's a question of trends so
you know it depends how big
your business is trying to be right but
if i were signing up a thousand people a
week and they all retain like the
retention curves for those cohorts
looked good healthy
and even like
as you started getting more people on
the service maybe those earlier cohorts
started curving up again because now
there are network effects and their
friends are on the service or totally
depends what type of business you're in
but i'm talking purely social right
um
i don't think it's an absolute
number i think it is a i guess you could
call it a marginal number so i spend a
lot of time when i work with startups
asking them like okay have you looked at
that cohort versus this cohort whether
it's your clients or whether it's people
signing up for uh the service
but a lot of people think you just have
to hit some mark like 10 000 people or
50 000 people
but really
seven-ish billion people in the world
most people forever will not know about
your product there are always more
people out there to sign up it's just a
question of how you turn on the spigot
so
at that stage early stage
yourself but also by way of advice
should you worry about money at all how
this thing is going to make money or do
you just try to find product market fit
and get a lot of users to enjoy using
your thing
i think it totally depends and that's an
unsatisfying answer um i was talking
with a friend today
who
he was one of our earlier investors and
he was saying hey like have you been
doing any angel investing lately i said
not really i'm just like focused on what
i want to do next and
he said the number of financings have
just gone bonkers like just bonk
like people are throwing money
everywhere right now um
and
i think the question is
do you have an inkling of how you're
gonna make money
or are you really just like waving your
hands i would not like to be an
entrepreneur in the position of
well i have no idea how this will
eventually make money that's not fun um
if you are in an area like let's say you
wanted to start a social network right
not saying this is a good idea but if
you did
they're only a handful of ways they've
made money and really only one way
they've made money in the past and
that's ads
so
you know
if you
have a service that's amenable to that
and
then i wouldn't worry too much about
that because if you get to the scale you
can hire some smart people and figure
that out
i
do think that is really healthy for a
lot of startups these days especially
the ones doing like
enterprise software
slacks of the world etc to be worried
about money from the beginning but
mostly as a way of winning over clients
and having stickiness um
i think i like of course you need to be
worried about money but i'm going to
also say this again which is
it's like long-term profitability
if you have a roadmap to that then
that's great
but if you're just like i don't know
maybe never like we're working on this
meta first thing i think maybe someday
i don't know like that seems harder to
me um so you have to be as big as
facebook to like finance that bet right
do you think it's possible you said
you're not saying it's necessarily a
good idea to launch a social network
do you think it's possible
today
maybe you can put yourself in those
shoes
to launch a social network that achieves
the scale of a facebook
or a twitter or an instagram and maybe
even greater scale absolutely
how do you do it
asking for a friend yeah if i knew i i'd
probably be doing it right now and not
sitting here so
i mean there's a lot of ways to ask this
question one is create a totally new
product market fit create a new market
create something like instagram did
which is like create something kind of
new
or
literally out compete facebook at its
own thing or i'll compete twitter at its
own thing
the only way to compete now if you want
to build a large social network is to
look for the cracks look for the
openings
um
you know
no one competed
i mean no one competed with the core
business of google no one competed with
the core business of microsoft
you don't go at
the big guys doing exactly what they're
doing
instagram didn't win quote unquote
because it tried to be
a visual twitter like
we spotted things that either twitter
wasn't going to do or refused to do
images and feed for the longest time
right
or that facebook wasn't doing or not
paying attention to because they were
mostly desktop at the time and we were
purely mobile
purely visual
often there are opportunities sitting
there you just have to you have to
you have to figure out like uh i think
like there's a strategy book i can't
remember the name but talk about moats
and just like the best place to play
is where your competitor like literally
can't pivot because structurally they're
set up not to be there
and that's where you win um
and what's fascinating is like do you
know how many people are like images
facebook does that twitter does that i
mean how wrong were they really wrong
these are some of the smartest people in
silicon valley right
but now instagram exists for a while
how is it that snapchat could then exist
makes no sense
like plenty of people would say well
there's facebook no images okay okay i
mean instagram i'll give you that one
but wait now another image based social
network's gonna get really big
and then tick tock comes along
like
the prior so you asked me is it possible
the only answer and reason i'm answering
yes is because
my prior is that it's happened once
every i don't know three four or five
years
consistently and i can't imagine there's
anything structurally that would change
that
so that's why i answer that way not
because i know how i just
when you see a pattern you see a pattern
and there's no reason to believe that's
going to stop and it's subtle too
because like you said snapchat and tick
tock they're all doing the same space of
things but there's something
fundamentally different about
like a three second video and a five
second video and a 15 second video in a
one minute video and a one hour video
right like fundamentally different
fundamentally different i mean i think
one of the reasons snapchat exists is
because instagram was so focused on
posting great beautiful manicured
versions of yourself throughout time
and there was this enormous demand of
like hey i really like this behavior i
love using instagram but
man i just like wish i could share
something going on in my day like
do i really have to put it on my profile
do i really have to make it last forever
do i really
um and that opened up a door it created
a market right and then what's
fascinating is
instagram had an explore page for the
longest time it was image driven right
um
but there's absolutely a behavior where
you open up instagram and you sit on the
explore page all day that is effectively
tick tock but obviously focused on
videos and it's not like you could just
put the explore page in tik tok form and
it works it had to be video it had to
have music
these are the hard parts about product
development that are very hard to
predict
but um
they're all versions of the same thing
with varying
if you line them up in a bunch of
dimensions they're just like
kind of on
they're different values of the same
dimensions which is like i guess easy to
say in retrospect but like if i were an
entrepreneur going after that area i'd
ask myself like where's the opening
what needs to exist because tiktok
exists now
so i wonder how much
things that don't yet exist and can
exist is in the space of algorithms in
the space of recommender systems
so
in the space of how the feed is
generated so we kind of talk about the
actual elements of the um
the content that's what we've been
talking the difference between photos
between uh short videos longer videos i
wonder how much disruption is possible
in the way the algorithms work
because a lot of the criticism towards
social media is in the way the
algorithms work currently and it feels
like
first of all talking about
product market fit there's certainly a
hunger
for
um social media
algorithms that do something different i
don't think anyone everyone said
complaining this is not doing this is
this is hurting me and this is hurting
society but i keep doing it because i'm
addicted to it
and they say we want something different
but we don't know what it feels like a
uh
just different uh it feels like there's
a hunger for that
but that's in the space of algorithms i
wonder if it's possible to disrupt in
that space absolutely
um
i have this thesis that
the worst part about social networks is
that they're uh
is the people
it's it's
it's a line that sounds funny right
because like that's why you call it a
social network um but what does social
networks actually do for you like just
think you know like
imagine you were an alien and you landed
and someone says hey there's this site
it's a social network we're not going to
tell you what it is but just what does
it do and you have to explain it to them
it does two things one is that
people you know and have social ties
with
uh distribute updates through whether
it's uh you know photos or videos
about their lives so that you don't have
to physically be with them but you can
keep in touch with them that's one
that's like a big part of instagram
that's a big part of snap
it is not part of tick tock at all so
there's another big part which is
there's all this content out in the
world that's entertaining
whether you want to watch it or you want
to read it
um
and matchmaking between content that
exists in the world and
uh people that want that content turns
out to be like a really big business
right search and discovery would you
search and discovery but my point is it
could be video it could be text it could
be websites it could be i mean think
back to um
think back to like dig right or stumble
upon or
right
nice
yeah but like what did those do like
they basically distributed interesting
content to you right
um
i think the most interesting part or the
future of social networks is going to be
making them less social because i think
people are part of the root cause of the
problem so for instance
um often in recommender systems we talk
about two stages there's a candidate
generation step
which is just like of our vast trove of
stuff that you might want to see
what small subset
should we pick for you
okay
typically that is grabbed from things
your friends have shared
right
then there's a ranking step which says
okay now given these hundred 200 things
depends on the network right let's like
be really good about ranking them and
generally rank the things up higher that
get the most engagement right so what's
the problem with that
step one is we've limited everything you
could possibly see to things that your
friends have chosen to share
or maybe not friends but influencers
what things do people generally want to
share they want to share things that are
going to get likes that are going to
show up broadly
so they tend to be more emotionally
driven they tend to be more risque or
whatever so why do we have this problem
it's because
we show people things people have
decided to share and those things
self-select to being the things that are
most divisive
so how do you fix that
well
what if you just
imagine for a second that why do you
have to grab things from things your
friends have shared why not just like
grab things
that's really fascinating to me and
that's something i've been thinking a
lot about and just like
you know why is it that when you log on
to twitter
you're just sitting there looking at
things from accounts that you've
followed for whatever reason
and tick tock i think has done a
wonderful job here which is like you can
literally be anyone
and if you produce something
fascinating it'll go viral
but like
you don't have to be someone that anyone
knows you don't have to have built up a
giant following you don't have to have
paid for followers
you don't have to try to maintain those
followers you literally just have to
produce something interesting
that is i think the future of social
networking that's the that's the
direction things will head and i think
what you'll find is it's far less about
people manipulating distribution and far
more about what is like is this content
good
and good is obviously a vague definition
that we spend hours on but
different networks i think will decide
different value functions to decide what
is good and what isn't good and i i
think that's a fascinating direction so
that's almost like creating an internet
i mean that's what google did for web
pages
they did the
you know page rank search
so discovery you don't you don't follow
anybody on google when you use a search
engine you just discover web pages and
so what tick tock does
is saying let's start from scratch
let's like like start a new internet and
have people discover stuff on that new
internet within a particular kind of
pool of people well what's so
fascinating about this is like the
the um field of information retrieval
like i always talked about and as i was
studying this stuff they would always
use the word query and document so i was
like why are they saying query
undocuments like they're literally
imagine like
if you just stop thinking about query as
like literally a search query and a
query could be a person i mean a lot of
the way
i'm not going to claim to know how
instagram or facebook machine learning
works today
but
you know if you want to find a match for
a query the query is actually the
attributes of the person
their age their gender where they're
from
maybe some kind of summarization of
their interests and and that's a query
right and that matches against documents
and by the way documents don't have to
be text they can be
videos they're however long i don't know
what the limit is on tick tock these
days they keep changing it my point is
just
you've got a query which is someone in
search of something that they want to
match and you've got the document it
doesn't have to be text it could be
anything and how do you match make and
that's one of these like i mean i've
spent a lot of time thinking about this
and i don't claim to have mastered it at
all
but i think it's so fascinating about
where that will go with new social
networks see what i'm also fascinated by
is metrics that are different than
engagement
so the other thing from an alien
perspective
what social networks are doing
is they
they in the short term bring out
different aspects of each human being so
first let me say
that
an algorithm or a social network
for each individual can bring out
the best of that person or the worst of
that person or there's a bunch of
different parts to us parts we're proud
of
that
that we are parts we're not so proud of
when we look at the big picture of our
lives when we look back 30 days from now
am i proud that i said those things or
not am i proud that i felt those things
am i proud that i experienced or read
those things or thought about those
things just in that kind of
self-reflective kind of way
and so coupled with that i wonder if
it's possible to have different metrics
they're not just about engagement
but are about
long-term happiness
growth of a human being well they look
back and say
i am a better human being for having
spent 100 hours on that app
and
that feels like it's actually strongly
correlated with engagement
in the long term in the short term it
might not be but in long term it's like
the same kind of thing where you really
fall in love with the product
you fall in love with an iphone you fall
in love with a car
that's what makes you fall in love is
like
really
being proud
and just
in a self-reflective way understanding
that you're a better human being for
having used the thing and that's like
where the f
that's what great relationships are made
from it's not just like you're hot
and we like being together or something
like that it's more like i'm a better
human being because i'm with you
and that feels like a metric that could
be optimized for by the algorithms
um but you know anytime i kind of talk
about this with anybody they seem to say
yeah okay that's going to get out
competed immediately by the engagement
if it's ad driven especially
i just don't think so
i don't i mean
a lot of is just implementation
i'll say a couple things one is to
pull back the curtain on daily meetings
inside of these large social media
companies
a lot of what
management or at least the people that
are are tweaking these algorithms spend
their time on our trade-offs
and there's these things called value
functions which are like okay
we can predict the probability that
you'll click on this thing or the
probability that you'll share it or the
probability that you will leave a
comment on it or the probability
you'll dwell on it
individual actions right
and you've got this neural network that
basically has a bunch of heads at the
end and all of them are between zero and
one and
great they all have values right or
or they all have probabilities
um
and then in these meetings what they
will do is say well uh
how much do we value a comment versus a
click versus a share versus a
and then maybe even some downstream
thing right that has nothing to do with
the item there but like
driving follows or something
and what typically happens is they will
say well what are our goals for this
quarter at the company oh we want to
drive sharing up okay well let's uh turn
down these metrics and turn up these
metrics
and and they blend them right into a
single scaler with which they're trying
to optimize
that is really hard because invariably
you think you're solving for i don't
know something called meaningful
interactions right
this was the big facebook pivot and i i
don't actually have any internal
knowledge like i wasn't in those
meetings
but at least from from what we've seen
over the last month or so it seems by
actually trying to trying to optimize
for meaningful interactions it had all
these side effects of optimizing for
these other things
and i don't claim to fully understand
them but what i will say
is that trade-offs abound
and as much as you'd like to solve for
one thing if you have a network of over
a billion people
you're gonna have unintended
consequences either way and it gets
really hard
so what you're describing is effectively
a value model that says like can we
capture this is the thing that i spent a
lot of time thinking about like can you
capture
utility
in a way that like actually measures
someone's happiness
that isn't just a um
what do they call it a surrogate problem
where you say well i kind of think like
the more you use the product
the happier you are that was always the
argument at facebook by the way it was
like well
people use it more so they must be more
happy yeah turns out they're like a lot
of things you use more that make you
less happy in the world not talking
about facebook just you know let's think
about
whether it's gambling or whatever like
that you can do more of but doesn't
necessarily make you happier so the idea
that time equals happiness obviously
you can't map utility and time together
easily there are a lot of edge cases
so when you look around the world and
you say well what are all the ways we
can model utility that is like one of
the
please if you know someone smart doing
this introduce me because i'm fascinated
by it and it seems really tough
but the idea that reinforcement learning
like everyone interesting i know in
machine learning like i was really
interested in recommender systems and
supervised learning and
and the more i dug into it i was like oh
literally everyone smart is working on
reinforcement learning
like literally everyone you just made
people at open ai and deep mind very
happy yes but i mean but what's
interesting is like it's one thing to
train a game and like
i mean that paper that where they just
took atari and they used a convnet to
basically just like train simple actions
mind-blowing right absolutely
mind-blowing but it's a game great
so now what if you're constructing
a feed for a person right
like
how can you
construct that feed in such a way
that optimizes for a diversity of
experience a
a long term happiness right
but that reward function it turns out in
reinforcement learning again
as i've learned
like reward design is really hard
and
i don't know like how do you design a
scalar reward for someone's happiness
over time i mean do you have to measure
dopamine levels like do you have to well
you have to have a lot of
a lot more signals from the human being
currently it feels like there's not
enough signals coming from the human
being users of uh
of this algorithm so for reinforcement
learning to work well
it needs to have a lot more data
needs to have a lot of data and that
actually is a challenge for anyone who
wants to start something which is you
don't have a lot of data so how do you
compete but i do think back to your
original point rethinking the algorithm
rethinking reward functions rethinking
utility
that's fascinating that's cool and i
think that's an open opportunity for
for a company that figures it out
i have to ask about april 2012
when instagram
along with its massive
employee base of 13 people was sold to
facebook for 1 billion dollars
what was the process like on a business
level engineering level human level what
was that process of selling to facebook
like what did it feel like
so i want to provide some context which
is i worked in corporate development at
google
which not a lot of people know but
corporate development is effectively the
group that buys companies right you sit
there and you acquire companies and i
had sat through so many of these
meetings with entrepreneurs we actually
fun fact we never acquired a single
company when i worked in corporate
development so i can't claim that
um i had like a lot of experience
but i had enough experience to
understand okay like what prices are
people getting and what's the process
and
and as we started to grow
you know
we were trying to keep this thing
running and we were exhausted and we
were 13 people and i mean we were trying
to think back he was probably 27
37 now um
so
young
and on a relative basis right and uh
we're trying to keep the thing running
and then you know we go out to raise
money and
we're kind of like the hot startup at
the time
and i remember going into a specific vc
and saying our terms we're looking for
are we're looking for a 500 million
valuation
and i've never seen so many jaws drop
all in unison right
and i was like thanked and walked out
the door very kindly after
um and then i got a call the next day uh
from someone who was connected to them
and said they said
we just want to let you know that like
uh it was pretty offensive that you
asked for a 500 billion dollar
evaluation and i i can't tell if that
was um
like just negotiating or what but it's
true like no one offered us more right
so we were so can you clarify the the
number again you said how many million
500 500 million 500 million yeah half a
billion yeah um
so in my mind i'm anchored like okay
well literally no one's biting at 500
million and eventually we would get
sequoia and greylock and others together
at 500 million basically uh post uh it
was 450 pre i think we raised 50 million
dollars but just like no one was used to
seeing 500 million dollar
companies then like i don't know if it
was because we were just coming out of
the hangover 2008 and things were still
on recovery
mode
but then along comes facebook and
after some negotiation
we've 2xed the number from a half a
billion to a billion
yeah it seems pretty good
you know
and uh i think mark and i really saw eye
to eye that this thing could be big um
we thought we could
their resources would help us scale it
and in a lot of ways it de-risks
i mean it degrees a lot of the employees
lives for the rest of their lives
including me including mike right
um i think i might have had like 10
grand in my bank account at the time
right like
we're working hard we had nothing um
so on a relative basis it seemed
very high and then i think the last
company to exit for anywhere close to a
billion was youtube that i could think
of
and uh and thus began the giant long
bull run of 2012 to all the way all the
way to where we are now where um i saw
some stat yesterday about like how many
unicorns exist and it's absurd
but then again never underestimate
technology and like the value
it can provide and man costs have
dropped and man scale has increased and
you can make businesses make a lot of
money now but on a on a fundamental
level
i don't know like how do you describe
the decision to sell a company with 13
people for a billion dollars so first of
all like how
did it take a lot of guts to set a table
and say 500 million or 1 billion with
mark zuckerberg
it seems like a very large number with
13. like especially like it doesn't seem
it is it is they're all larger
especially like you said before
the unicorn
parade
i like that i'm going to use that
unicorn
yeah the uh the the you are at the head
of the unicorn parade it's the uh yeah
it's a massive unicorn parade um okay so
no i mean we knew we were worth
quote-unquote a lot but we didn't i mean
there was no market for instagram i mean
it's not you could mark you couldn't
mark to market this thing in the public
markets you didn't quite understand what
it would be worth or it was worth at the
time
so in a market an illiquid market where
you have one buyer and one seller and
you're going back and forth and
well i guess there were
like vc firms who are willing to
you know invest at a certain valuation
so
i don't know you just go with your gut
and uh and at the end of the day i would
say um
the hardest part
of it was not realizing uh
like when we sold it was tough because
like literally everywhere i go
restaurants whatever like
for a good six months after there was a
lot of attention on the deal a lot of
attention on the product a lot of
attention it was kind of miserable right
and you're like wait like i made a lot
of money but like why is this not great
and it's because it turns out you know
and i don't i don't know like i don't
really keep in touch with mark but i've
got to assume his job right now is not
exactly the most happy job in the world
it's really tough when you're on top and
it's really tough when you're in the
limelight
so the decision itself was like oh cool
this is great how lucky are we right so
okay there's a million questions yeah go
first of all first of all
why
why is it hard to be on top why did you
not feel good
like can you dig into that it always um
i've heard like olympic athletes say
after what they win gold they they get
depressed
is it something like that where
it feels like
it was kind of like a thing you were
working towards yeah some some loose
definition of success and this sure
psych feels like
uh at least according to other startups
this is what success looks like and now
why don't i feel any
better i'm still human i still have all
the same problems is that the nature or
is it just like negative attention or
some kind what i think it's all of the
above um but to be clear there was a lot
of happiness in terms of like oh my god
this is great like we
like won the super bowl of startups
right um anyone who
can get to a liquidity event of anything
meaningful feels like wow this is what
we started out to do of course we want
to create great things that people love
but
um
like we won in a big way but yeah
there's this big like oh if we won what
is like what's next i don't so
they call it the we have arrived
syndrome
um
which i i need to go back and look where
i can quote that from but i remember
reading about it at the time i was like
oh yeah that's that
i remember we had a product manager
leave very early on when we got to
facebook and he said to me um i just
don't believe i can learn anything at
this company anymore it's like it's hit
its
apex we sold it great i just don't have
anything else to learn
so from 2012 all the way to the day i
left in 2018 like the amount i learned
and the humility with which i realized
oh we thought we won
billion dollars is cool but like there
are a hundred billion dollar companies
and by the way on top of that
we had no revenue we had i mean we had a
cool product but we didn't scale it yet
and
there's so much to learn and then
competitors and how fun was it to fight
snapchat oh my god like it was
it's like yankees red sox it's great
like that's what you live for um
you know you win some you lose some but
uh the amount you can learn through that
process uh
what i've realized
in life is that there is no end there's
always someone who has more there's
always more challenge just at different
scales and uh it sounds like a little
buddhist but um
everything is super challenging whether
you're like a small business or an
enormous business
i say like choose the game you like to
play right you've got to imagine that if
you're an amazing basketball player you
enjoy to some extent practicing
basketball it's got to be something you
love it's going to suck it's going to be
hard
you're going to have injuries right but
you got to love it and the same thing
with instagram which is
um
we might have sold but it was like great
there's one super bowl title can we win
five what else can we do
now i imagine you didn't ask this but
okay so i left
there's a little bit of like what do you
do next right like what do you how do
you top that thing it's the wrong
question
the question is like when you wake up
every day
what is the hardest most interesting
thing you can go work on
because like at the end of the day we
all turn into dirt doesn't matter right
but what does matter is like can we
really enjoy this life not in a
hedonistic way because that's those
it's like the reinforcement learning
learning like short term versus
long-term objectives
can you wake up every day and truly
enjoy what you're doing
um
knowing that it's going to be painful
knowing that like no matter what you
choose it's going to be painful um
whether you sit on a beach or whether
you manage a thousand people or ten
thousand it's gonna be painful so choose
something that's fun
to have pain
um but yes there was uh there was a lot
of we have arrived and um
it's a maturation process you just have
to go through so no matter how much
success is there is how much money you
make you have to wake up the next day
and choose the hard life whatever that
means next that's fun the fun slash hard
life
hard life that's fun i guess
what i'm trying to say is slightly
different which is just that no one
realizes
everything's gonna be hard
even chilling out
is hard and then you just start worrying
about stupid stuff like i don't know
like
did so and so forget to paint the house
today or like did the gardener come or
whatever like yeah or oh i'm so angry
and my shipment of wine didn't show up
and i'm sitting here on the beach
without my wine i don't know i'm making
up now but like it turns out that
even chilling aka meditation is hard
work yeah i and at least meditation is
like productive chilling where you're
like actually training yourself to calm
down and be but
backing up for a moment everything's
hard you might as well be like
playing in the game you love to play i
just like playing and winning and
and i'm i'm on the on the i'm still on
the i think the first half of life knock
on wood um
and i've got a lot of years what am i
going to do sit around and the other way
of looking at this by the way
um
imagine you made one movie it was great
would you just like stop making movies
no generally you're like wow i really
like making movies let's make another
one a lot of times by the way the second
one or the third one not that great but
the fourth one awesome
and no one forgets the sec everyone
forgets the second and the third one so
there's just this constant process of
like can i produce
and is that fun is that exciting what
else can i learn so this machine
learning stuff for me has been this
awesome new chapter
of being like
man that's something i didn't understand
at all and now i feel like i'm one-tenth
of the way there
and that feels like a big mountain to
climb uh
so i distracted us from the original
question no
return to machine learning because i'd
love to explore your interest there but
i mean speaking of sort of challenges
and hard things is there a possible
world
where sitting in a room with mark
zuckerberg
with a one billion dollar deal
you turn it down yeah of course
what does that world
look like why would you turn it down why
did you take it what was the calculation
that you were making ah thus enters the
world of
counterfactuals and not really knowing
and if only we could run that experiment
well the universe exists it's just
running in parallel to our own yeah
it's so fascinating right um
i mean we're talking a lot about money
but the real question was
um
i'm not sure you'll believe me when i
say this but
could we strap our little company onto
the side of a rocket ship
and like get out to a lot of people
really really quickly with the support
with the
the talent
of a place like facebook i mean people
often ask me what i would do differently
um at instagram today and i say well i
probably hire more carefully because we
showed up
just like before i knew it we had like
100 people on the team and 200 and 300 i
don't know where all these people were
coming from i never had to recruit them
i never had to screen them they were
just like internal transfers right
so it's like relying on the facebook
hiring machine which is quite sort of
i mean it's an elaborate machine it's
and it's great by the way they have
really talented people there
but my point is um
the choice was like take this thing put
it on the side of a rocket ship that you
know is growing very quickly
like i had seen what had happened when
ev sold blogger to google and then
google went public remember we sold
before facebook went public
there was a moment at which the stock
price was 17 by the way the facebook
stock price was 17 i remember thinking
what the f did i just do right
uh now at
320-ish i don't know where we are today
but like
okay like
the best thing by the way is like
when the stock is down everyone calls
you dope and then when it's up they also
call you a dope but just for a different
reason
right like you can't win lesson in there
somewhere yeah so but you know the
choice is to stripe yourself to a rocket
ship or to build your own you know mr
elon built his own
literally with the rocket ship
that's a difficult choice because um
there's a world
actually i would say something different
which is elon and others decided to sell
paypal
for
not that much i mean how much was it
about a billion dollars i can't remember
something like that yeah i mean it was
early and um but it's worth a lot more
an hour and then build a new rocket ship
so this is the cool part right if you
are
an entrepreneur and you own a
controlling stake in the company
not only is it really hard to do
something else with your life because
all of the
you know value is tied up in you as a
personality attached to this company
right
but if you sell it and you get yourself
enough capital and you like have enough
energy
you could do another thing or 10 other
things or in elon's case like a bunch of
other things i don't know like i lost
count at this point um
and it might have seemed silly at the
time and sure like if you look back man
paypal's worth a lot now right
but i don't know like do you think elon
like cares about like are we gonna buy
pinterest or not like i just he is
he created a a a massive capital that
allowed him to do what he wants to do
and that's awesome that's more freeing
than anything because when you are an
entrepreneur attached to a company you
gotta stay at that company for a really
long time it's really hard to remove
yourself but i'm not sure how much he
loved paypal versus spacex and tesla
i have a sense that you love
instagram
yeah i loved enough to like
work for six years beyond that which is
rare which is very rare you chose but
can i tell you why sure it's um
please
there are not a lot of companies that
you can be part of where
the pope's like i would like to sign up
for your product like i'm not a
religious person at all
i'm really not um yeah but when you go
to the vatican and you're like walking
among the giant columns and you're
hearing the music and everything and
like
the pope walks in and he wants to press
the sign up button on your product like
it's a moment in life okay um no matter
what your persuasion okay
the number of doors and experiences that
that opened up was it was incredible i
mean the people i got to meet the places
i got to go
um i assume maybe like a payments
company is slightly different right
but that's why like it was so fun and
plus i truly believed we were building
such a great product and i loved loved
the game it wasn't about the money it
was about the game
do you think do you think you had the
guts to say no
is that so his i often think about this
like
how hard is it for entrepreneur to say
no because
the peer pressure so every like
basically the sea of entrepreneurs in
silicon valley are going to tell you
this is their dream
the the the thing you were sitting
before was is a dream to walk away from
that is really
it seems like nearly impossible
because instagram
could in 10 years
be you know you could talk about google
you could be making self-driving cars
and building rockets that go to mars and
compete with spacex totally and so
that's an interesting decision to say
am i willing
to risk it and the reason i also say
it's an interesting decision because
it feels like per previous discussion if
you're launching a social
uh social network company
there's there's going to be that meeting
whatever that number is if you're
successful if if you're on this rocket
ship of success there's going to be a
meeting
with one of the social media
social network companies
that want to buy you
uh whether it's facebook or twitter but
it could also very well be google who
seems to
have like a graveyard of failed social
networks
and it's
i mean i don't know i i i think about
that how difficult it is for the
entrepreneur to make that decision
how many have successfully made that
decision i guess this is a big question
it's sad to me to be honest that too
many make that decision perhaps for the
wrong reason to to so when you say make
the decision you mean to the affirmative
affirmative you got it yeah there are
also companies that don't sell right and
take the path and say we're going to be
independent and then you've never heard
of them again
like i remember uh path right was one of
our competitors early on
uh there's a big moment when they had i
can't remember what it was like 110
million offer from google or something
it might have been larger i don't know
um
and i remember there was like this big
techcrunch article that was like they
turned it down after talking deeply
about their values and everything and
i don't i don't know the inner workings
of foursquare but like i'm certain there
were many conversations over time where
there were companies that wanted
foursquare as well um recently
like i mean what other companies
there's clubhouse right like i don't
know maybe people were really interested
in them too
like
there are plenty of moments
where people say no
and we just forget that those things
happen we only focus on the ones where
like
uh uh they said yes and like wow like
what if they had stayed independent so i
don't know i like i used to think a lot
about this and now i just don't because
i'm like whatever i you know like things
have gone pretty well yeah
i'm ready for the next game i mean think
about um an athlete
where
i don't know maybe they they they do
something wrong in the world series or
whatever and like if you let it haunt
you for the rest of your career like
why not just be like i don't know it was
a game next game next shot right and if
if you just move to that world like at
least i have a next shot right no that's
that's beautiful but i mean just in
insights uh and it's funny you brought
up clubhouse it is very true it seems
like clubhouse is uh
you know
on the downward path and it's very
possible to see
a billion plus dollar deal at some stage
maybe like a year ago or half a year ago
from facebook from google i think
facebook was flirting with that idea too
and i think a lot of companies probably
were
i wish it was more public
you know what there's not like a badass
public story about them making the
decision to walk away we just don't hear
about it and then we get to see the the
results of that success or the failure
more often failure
so a couple things one is i would not
assume clubhouse is down for the count
at all they're young they have plenty of
money they're run by really smart people
i'd give them like a very fighting
chance to figure it out there are a lot
of times when people call twitter down
for the count and they figure it out and
they seem to be doing well right yeah um
so just backing up like and not knowing
anything about their internals like
there's a strong chance they will figure
it out and that people are just down
because they like being down about
companies they like assuming that
they're going to fail so who knows right
but let's take the ones in the past
where like we know how it played out
there are plenty of examples where
people have turned down big offers and
then you've just never heard from them
again but we never focus on the
companies because you just forget that
those were big but inside your psyche
i think they're um
it's easy for someone with enough money
to say money doesn't matter which i
think is like it's of course
money matters to people um
but at the moment you just can't even
grasp like the number of zeros that
you're talking about it just doesn't
make sense
right
so to think rationally in that moment is
not something many people are equipped
to do especially not people where i
think we had founded the company a year
earlier maybe two years earlier like a
year and a half we were 13 people
but um i will say
i still don't know if it was the right
decision because i don't have that
counterfactual i don't know that other
world
i'm just thankful that
by and large most people love instagram
still do
by and large people are very happy with
like the time we had there
um and i'm proud of what we built so
like
i'm cool like we're you know now now
it's it's next shot right
well if we could just linger on this
yankees versus red sox the fun of it the
competition over i would say over the
space of features
so um
there are a bunch of features
like there's
photos
there's one minute videos on instagram
there's igtv there's stories there's
reels there's live
so that sounds like it's like a long
list of too much stuff but it's it's not
because it feels like they're
they're close together but they're
somehow like what we're saying
fundamentally distinct like each of the
things i mentioned
maybe can you describe the philosophies
the design philosophies behind some of
these how you were thinking about it
during the uh
the historic war between snapchat and
instagram or just in general like
this space of features that was
discovered there's this um
great book by clay christensen called
competing against luck it's like a
terrible uh title
but within it there's uh effectively an
expression of this thing called jobs to
be done theory
and it's unclear if like he came up with
it or some of his colleagues but
everyone there are a bunch of places you
can find with people claiming to have
come up with this jobs to be done theory
but the idea is if you if you like
zoom out and you look at your product
you ask yourself why are people hiring
your product
like imagine every product in your life
is effectively an employee
you know your ceo of your life and you
hire products to be employees
effectively they all have roles and jobs
right
why are you hiring a product why do you
want that product to perform something
in your life and what like what are the
hidden reasons why uh you're you're in
love with this product
instagram was about sharing your life
with others visually period right
why because you feel connected with them
you get to show off
you get to feel good and and cared about
right with likes and
um and it turns out that
that will i think forever define
instagram and any product that serves
that job is going to do very well
okay
stories let's take it as an example
is very much serving that job in fact it
serves it better than the original
product because when you're large and
have an enormous audience
you're worried about people seeing your
stuff or you're worried about being
permanent so that a college admissions
person is going to see your photo of you
doing something and
so it turns out that that is a more
efficient way of performing that job
than the original product was the
original product still has its value
but at scale these two things together
work really really well
now
i will claim that other parts of the
product over time
didn't perform that job as well i think
igtv probably didn't right
shopping is like completely unrelated to
what i just described but it might work
i don't know right um
products i think
products that succeed
are products that all share this parent
node
of like this job to be done that is in
common and then they're just like
different ways of doing it right
apple i think does a great job with this
right it's like managing your digital
life and all the products just work
together they sink they like it's
beautiful right
even if they require like silly specific
cords to work
but they're all part of a system
it's when you leave that system and you
start doing something weird that people
start scratching their head
and i think you are less successful so i
think one of the challenges facebook has
had throughout its life
is that it has never fully i think
appreciated the job to be done of the
main product and what it's done is said
oh there's a shiny object over there
that starts getting some traction let's
go copy that thing and then they're
confused why it doesn't work like why
doesn't it work it's because the people
who show up for this don't want that
it's different what's the purpose of
facebook i remember i was a very early
facebook user i was the reason i was
personally excited about facebook
is um
because you can first of all use your
real name
like i i can exist in this world it can
be like
formally exist there's i i like
anonymity for certain things reddit and
so on but i want it to also exist
uh
not anonymously so that that can connect
with other friends of mine
not anonymously and there's a reliable
way to know
that i'm real and they're real and that
we're connecting and though it's kind of
like um i liked it for the for the
reasons that people like linkedin i
guess
but like without the form like not
everybody is dressed up and being super
polite like more like with friends
but then it became something much bigger
than that i suppose there's a feed it
it became this um
i mean it became a place to
get
discover content
to share content that's not just about
connecting directly with friends i mean
it becomes something else i don't even
know what it is really so you said
instagram is a place where you visually
share your
life
what is facebook
well let's go back to the founding of
facebook and why it worked really well
initially at harvard and then dartmouth
and stanford and i can't remember
probably mit there were like a handful
of schools in that first tranche right
um
it worked because there are communities
that exist in the world
that want to transact and when i say
transact i don't mean commercially i
just mean
they want to share they want to
coordinate they want to communicate they
want a space for themselves
and facebook at its best i think
is that and if actually you look at the
most popular products that facebook has
built over time
if you look at things that like groups
marketplace groups is enormous yeah and
groups is effectively like everyone can
found their own little stanford or
dartmouth or mit right and and find each
other and and
and share and communicate about
something that matters deeply to them
that is the core of what facebook was
built around and i think today
is where it stands most uh most strongly
yeah it's brilliant the groups i wish um
i wish groups were done better it feels
like it's not a first-class citizen i
know
i may be saying something without much
knowledge but
it feels like it's uh it's kind of
bolted on
while being used a lot it feels like
there needs to be a little bit more
structure in terms of discovery
in terms of
yeah like i mean look at reddit like red
is basically groups yeah public and open
and a little bit a little bit crazy
right in a good way yeah um but there's
clear product market fit for that
specific use case and it doesn't have to
be a college it can be anything it can
be a small group big group it can be
group messaging
facebook shines i think when it leans
into that i think when there are other
companies
that just seem exciting and now all of a
sudden the product shifts in some
fundamental way to go
try to compete with that other thing
that's when i think consumers get
confused
um even if you can be successful like
even if you can compete with that other
company even if you can
figure out how to bolt it on eventually
you come back and you look at the app
and you're like i just don't know why i
opened this app like why like too many
things going on and that was always a
worry i mean you listed all the things
at instagram and it almost gave me a
heart attack like
way too many things but i don't know
entrepreneurs get bored they want to add
things they want to like right um
i don't have a good answer for it except
for that um
i think being true to your original use
case and not even original use case but
sorry actually not use case original job
there are many use cases under that job
being true to that and like being really
good at it over time and and morphing as
as needs change
i think that's how to make a company
last forever and
i mean honestly i like
my main thesis about why facebook is in
the position it is today
is
if if they have had a series of product
launches that delighted people over time
i think they'd be in a totally different
world so just like imagine for a moment
and by the way apple's entering this but
like
apple for so long just like product
after product you couldn't wait for it
you stood in line for it you talked
about it you got excited
amazon makes your life so easy it's like
wow
i needed this thing and it showed up at
my door two days later and like
both of these companies by the way
amazon apple have issues right there are
labor issues
whether it's here in the us or in china
there are environmental issues there are
but like when's the last time you heard
like a large chorus being like
these companies better pay for what
they're doing on these things right
i think facebook's main issue today is
like i
you need to produce a hit if you don't
produce hits
it's really hard to keep consumers on
your side then people just start picking
on you and for a variety of reasons
whether it's right or wrong i'm not even
going to place a judgment right here
right now i'm just going to say that
it is way better to be in a world where
you are producing hits and consumers
love what you're doing
because then they're on your side and i
i think that's it's
the past 10 years for facebook has been
fairly hard on this dimension so and by
hits it doesn't necessarily mean
financial hits it feels like to me what
you're saying is something that brings a
joy yeah a product that brings joy to
some fraction of the population yeah i
mean
tick tock isn't just literally an
algorithm
in some ways tick tock's content uh and
algorithm have more sway now over the
american psyche than facebook's
algorithm right it's visual it's video
by the way it's not defined by who you
follow it's defined by some magical
thing that by the way if someone wanted
to tweak to show you a certain type of
content for some reason they could right
um
but people love it
so as a ceo let me ask you a question
because leadership matters
it's a complicated question
why is mark zuckerberg distrusted
disliked and sometimes even hated by
many people in public
right that is a complicated question um
well the premise
i'm not sure i agree with the premise um
and i can i can expand that to include
even a more mysterious question for me
bill gates hmm
what is the bill gates version of the
question
do you think people hate bill gates
no distrust ah
so uh take away one it's a checklist uh
there's
i think mark zuckerberg's distrust is
the primary one but there's also like a
like a dislike maybe hate is too strong
award but just if you look at like
the articles that are being written and
so on
there's a dislike and it makes it's
confusing to me because it's like the
public picks certain individuals and
they
and they attach certain kinds of
emotions to those individuals yeah so
someone once uh
just recently said
there's a strong case that founder-led
companies have this problem and that a
lot of mark's issues um come today come
from the fact that he is a visible
founder with this
story
that people have watched in both a movie
and they followed along and he's this
boy wonder kid who became one of the
world's richest people and
and he's no longer mark the person he's
marked this this image of of a person
with enormous wealth and power
and in today's world we we have issues
with enormous wealth and power for a
variety of reasons one of which is we've
been stuck inside
you know for a year and a half two years
uh one of which is a lot of people were
really unhappy about not the last
election but the last last election
and where do you take out that anger who
do you blame but the people in charge
that's one example or one reason why i
think
um a lot of people
uh express anger or resentment or
unhappiness with
with mark at the same time
i don't know i pointed out to that
person i was like well i don't know like
i think a lot of people really like elon
like
ilana arguably like he kept his you know
factory open here throughout covet
protocols which arguably a lot of people
would be against um
while saying a bunch of uh
crazy offensive things on the internet
they still like basically you know
gives the middle finger to the sec like
on twitter and like
i don't know i'm like well there's a
founder and like people kind of like him
i so i do think that
the so like the the founder and slash
ceo of a company that's a social network
company is like an extra level of
difficulty if if life is a video game
you just chose the harder video game
so i mean that's why it's interesting to
ask you because you were the
founder and the ceo oh yeah of a social
network right challenge because exactly
so but you're one of the rare
even jack dorsey's disliked
not to the degree but it just seems
harder when you're running a social
media company it's interesting i i never
thought of jack as just like i think
generally he's well respected um
yeah i think so i i think you're right
but like he's
but he's not loved
yeah
and i feel like you i mean to me twitter
is an incredible thing yeah
again can i just come back to this point
which seems over simplistic but like i
really do think
how a product makes someone feel yeah
they ascribe that feeling to the founder
yep
uh
so so make people feel good so think
about it like let's just go with this
thesis for a second sure i like it
though um
amazon's pretty utilitarian right it
delivers brown boxes to your front door
sure you can have alexa and you can have
all these things right
but in general it delivers stuff quickly
to you at a reasonable price right
i think jeff bezos is wonderfully
wealthy thoughtful smart guy right but
like people kind of feel that way about
them they're like wow this is really big
we're impressed that this is really big
and
but they he's doing the same space stuff
elon's doing but they don't necessarily
describe the same sense of wonder right
um now let's take elon uh and again this
is pet theory i don't have much proof
other than my own intuition um
he is literally about living the future
mars space it's about wonder it's about
going back to that feeling as a kid when
you looked up to the stars and asked is
there life out there people get behind
that because it's a sense of hope and
excitement and and innovation and like
you can say whatever you want but we
ascribe that emotion to that person
now let's say you're on a social network
and people make you kind of angry
because they disagree with you or they
say something ridiculous or they're
living
a fomo type life where you're like wow i
wish i was doing that thing
i think instagram if i were to think
back by and large when i was there was
not about fomo was not about this
influence or economy although it
certainly became that way closer to the
end
it was about the sense of wonder and
happiness and beautiful things in the
world and
i don't know i mean like i don't want to
have a blind spot but i don't think
anyone had a strong opinion about one
way or the other for the longest time
the way people explain to me i mean if
you want to go for toxicity you go to
facebook or twitter if you want to go to
make feel good about life you go to
instagram to enjoy celebrate life though
and my experience when talking to people
is they gave me the benefit of the doubt
because that but if your experience of
the product is kind of makes you angry
it's where you argue
i mean a big part of jack might be that
he wasn't actually the ceo for a very
long time and only became recently so
i'm not sure how much of the connection
got made
um
but in general i mean if you hate you
know
i'm just thinking about other companies
that aren't tech companies if you hate
like what a company is doing or it makes
you not feel happy
i don't know like people are really
angry about comcast or whatever are they
even called comcast anymore it's like
xfinity or something right they had to
rebrand they they became meta right um
it's like uh but my point is if it makes
you that's beautiful yeah
but the thing is
this is me saying this i think your
thesis is very
strong and correct
has elements of correctness but i still
personally
put some blame on individuals of course
i think uh
you said
elon looking up there's something about
childlike wander to him
like to to his personality his character
something about
i think more so than others where people
can trust them and there's uh i don't
know santa pachai is an example of
somebody who's like
there's some kind
it's it's hard to put into words but
there's something about the human being
where he's trustworthy yeah he's he's
human
in a way that uh connects to us and the
same with uh
sadji nadella i mean some of these folks
um something about
us is drawn to them even when they're
flawed even like um so like your thesis
really holds up for steve jobs because i
think people didn't like steve jobs but
like he delivered products
that and then they fell in love every
time
i guess you could say that the ceo the
leader is also a product
and if they keep delivering a product
that people like
by being in public and saying things
that people like that's also a way to
make people happy
but from a social network perspective it
makes me
wonder how difficult it is
to explain to people why certain things
happen like how to explain machine
learning to explain why
certain
uh
the
the woke mob effect happens or the
certain kinds of like bullying happens
which is like
it's human nature combined with
algorithm and it's very difficult to
control for how the spread of
quote-unquote misinformation happens
it's very difficult to control for that
and to you so you try to decelerate
certain parts and you create more
problems then you solve and anything
that looks at all like censorship can
create huge amounts of problems that's
the slippery slope and then you have to
inject humans to oversee the machine
learning algorithms and anytime you
inject humans into the system it's gonna
create a huge number of problems and i
feel like it's up to the leader to
communicate that effectively to be
transparent
uh first of all design products that
don't have those problems and second of
all when they have those problems to be
able to communicate with them i guess
that's all going to
when you run a social network company
your job is hard
yeah
i will say the one element that you
haven't named that i think you're
getting at is just bedside manner
which steve jobs
i never worked for him i never met him
in person um
had an enor like
an uncanny ability in public to have
bedside manner i mean some of the best
clips of steve jobs
are from like i would say
maybe the 80s when he's on these stage
and getting questions from the audience
about life or
and he'll take this question that is
like how are you going to compete with
blah and it's super boring and i don't
even know the name of the coming and his
answer is is if you just asked like your
grandfather the meaning of life yeah
yeah and you sit there and you're just
like what like yeah and there's that
bedside manner um
and if you lack that or if that's just
not intuitive to you
uh i think that
it can be a lot harder to gain the trust
of people and then add on top of that
missteps of companies right
it's i don't know if you have any
friends from the past where like maybe
they crossed you once or like
maybe you get back together and you're
friends again but you just never really
forget that thing it's human nature not
to forget i'm russian you cost me one
we solve the problem
so my point is
it there's
humans don't forget and if there are
times in the past where they feel like
they don't trust the company or the
company hasn't had their back
that is really hard to earn back
especially if you don't have that
bedside manner um and again like i'm not
attributing this specifically to mark
because i think a lot of companies
have this issue where
one you have to be trustworthy as a
company and live by it and live by those
actions and then two i think you need to
be able to be really relatable in a way
that's very difficult if you're worth
like what these people are it's really
hard
yeah
jack does a pretty good job of this
by being a monk but i also like jack
issues attention like he's not out there
almost on purpose he's just working hard
doing square right like
i literally shared a desk like this with
him at audio i mean just normal guy who
likes painting i like i remember he
would leave early on like wednesdays or
something to go to like a painting class
yeah and he's creative he's thoughtful i
mean
money makes people like more creative
and more thoughtful like extreme
versions of themselves right um and this
was a long long time ago
uh you mentioned that he uh he asked you
to do some kind of javascript thing
we were working on some javascript
together i like that's hilarious like
pre-twitter early twitter days you and
jack dorsey are in a room together
talking about javascript solving some
kind of menial problem terrible problems
yeah i mean not terrible just like
boring boring widget probably i think it
was the odo widget we were working on at
the time
i'm surprised anyone paid me to be in
the room as an intern because i didn't
really provide any value i'm very
thankful
to anyone who included me back in the
day uh it was very helpful so thank you
for listening i mean is there uh
odia that's a precursor to twitter
first of all did you have any
anticipation that this jack dorsey guy
could be
also a head of a major social network
and um second did you learn anything
from the guy that like did do do you
think it's a coincidence that you two
were in the room together
and it's
the coincidence meaning like
why does the world play its game in a
certain way were these two founders of
social networks i don't know it's so
weird right like i i mean it's also
weird that
mark showed up
you know in our fraternity my sophomore
year and
we got to know each other then like long
before instagram it's
it's a small world but
let me tell a fun story about jack um
we're at odio and i don't know i think
ev was feeling like people weren't
working hard enough or something
nice and
i can't remember exactly what he he
created this thing where every friday
i don't know if it was every friday i
only remember this happening once
but he had us like a statuette it's like
of mary and in the bottom it's it's
hollow right and
i remember on a friday he decided
decided he was going to let everyone
vote for who had worked the hardest that
week
we all voted closed ballot right we all
put in a bucket and he tallied the votes
and then whoever got the most votes as i
recall got the statuette
and in the statue it was a thousand
bucks whereas i recall there was a
thousand bucks tonight it might have
been a hundred bucks but let's call it a
thousand it's more exciting that way it
felt like a thousand yeah it did to me
for sure i actually got two votes i was
very happy we were a small company but i
as the intern i got at least two votes
so everybody knew how many votes they
got individually yeah yeah i think it
was one of these self-accountability
things anyway i remember jack just
getting like the vast majority of votes
from everyone
and i remember just thinking like
like i couldn't imagine he would become
what he'd become and do what he would do
but i had a profound respect that
the new guy
who i really liked
worked that hard and you could see his
dedication even then and that people
respected him
that's the one story that i remember of
him like working with him specifically
from that summer can take a small
tangent on that of course there's kind
of a push back in silicon valley a
little bit against hard work
can you speak to the sort of
the thing you admire to see the new guy
working so hard that thing
what is the value of that thing in a
company see this is i like just to be
very frank it drives me nuts like
i saw this really funny video on tick
tock was it on tick tock it was like i'm
taking a break from my mental health to
work on my career i thought that was
funny
um
[Laughter]
yeah so it's like oh it is kind of
phrased that way the opposite often
right yeah um okay so a couple things
uh
i uh
i have worked so hard
to do the things that i did like
mike and i lost years off of our lives
staying up late figuring things out
the stress that comes with the job i
have a lot more gray hair now than i did
back then
it requires an enormous amount of work
and most people aren't successful right
but even the ones that do don't skate by
um
i am okay if people choose not to work
hard because i don't actually think
there's anything in this world that says
you have to work hard um
but i do think that great things require
a lot of hard work so there's no way you
can expect to change the world without
working really hard and by the way
even changing the world
you know the folks that i respect the
most have nudged the world in like a
slight direction
slight
very very slight
like
even if elon accomplishes all the things
he wants to accomplish we will have uh
have nudged the world in a slight
direction but it requires enormous
amount there was an interview with him
where he was just like
he was interviewed i think at the tesla
factory and he was like
work is really hard this is actually
unhealthy
and i can't recall the exact but he was
like visibly shaken about how hard he
had been working and he was like this is
bad
and unfortunately i think to have great
outcomes you actually do need to work at
like three standard deviations above the
mean
but there's nothing saying that people
have to go for this the thing is but
what i would argue this is my personal
opinion is nobody has to do anything
first of all exactly they certainly
don't have to work hard exactly but
i think
hard work in a company should be admired
i do too and you should not feel
like
you shouldn't feel good about yourself
for not working hard
like
so for example i don't have to work out
i don't have to run
i hate running
but like i certainly don't feel good if
i don't run because i know for my health
like there's certain values i guess is
what i'm trying to get right the the
certain values that you have in life it
feels like there's certain values that
companies should have and hard work is
one of the things um
i think that should be admired i often
ask this kind of silly question
uh just just to get a sense of people
one that like if i'm hiring and so on i
just ask if they uh think it's better to
work hard or work smart
it was helpful for me to
get a sense of people from that
because you think like the right both
was that the answer was the answer's
both i usually try not to give them that
but sometimes i'll say both if that's an
option but a lot of people kind of
a surprising number will say work smart
and they're usually people who don't
know how to work smart
and uh they're they're literally just
lazy
not just there's two there's two effects
behind that it's one is laziness and the
other
is
ego
when you're younger and you say it's
better to work smart it means
you think you know what it means to work
smart at this early stage
to me people that say work hard or both
they have the humility to understand
like i'm going to have to work my ass
off because i'm too dumb to know how to
work smart and people who are
self-critical in this way in some small
amount you have to have some confidence
but
you have if you have humility that means
you're going to actually eventually
figure out what it means to work smart
and then to actually be successful you
should do both
so
i have a very particular take on this
which is that um
no one's forcing you to do anything all
choices have consequences
so
if you major in
i don't know theoretical literature i i
don't even know if that's a major i'm
just making something up as opposed to
regular literature like if but like
literature yeah think about like like
theoretical yeah
spanish lit from the 14th century like
just make make up your esoteric thing
and then the number of people i went to
stanford with who get out in the world
are like wait what i can't find a job
like no one wants a theoretical like
there are plenty of counter examples of
people have majored in esoteric things
and gone on to be very successful so i
just want to be clear it's not about the
major but
every choice you make
whether it's to have kids like
i love my children it's so awesome to
have two kids and it is so hard to work
really hard and also have kids it's
really hard and there's a reason why
certain very successful people like
don't have are not successful but people
who run very very large companies or
startups have chosen not to have kids
for a while or chosen not to like
prioritize them
everything's a choice and like i choose
to prioritize my children because like i
want to do that right
so everything's a choice
now once you've made that choice
i think it's important that the contract
is clear which is to say let's imagine
you were joining a new startup
it's important that that startup
communicate that like the expectation is
like we're all working really really
hard right now you don't have to join
the startup
but like if you do just know like you're
it's almost as if you join i don't know
pick your uh
pick your pick your like sports team
like let's go back to the yankees for a
second
you want to join the yankees but you
don't really want to work that hard you
don't really want to do batting practice
or pitching practice or whatever for
your position right
um
that to me is wacko and that's actually
the world that it feels like we live in
in tech sometimes where people both want
to work for the yankees because it pays
a lot but like don't actually want to
work that hard
that i don't fully understand because if
you sign up for some of these things
just sign up for it but it's okay if you
don't want to sign up for it there's so
many wonderful careers in this world
that don't require 80 hours a week but
when i read about companies going to
like four day work weeks and stuff i
just like i chuckle because i can't get
enough done with a seven day week i
don't know how
and people will say oh you're just not
working smart and it's like no i i work
pretty smart i think in general like i
would have gotten to this point if i
hadn't like some amount of working smart
and there is balance though so i used to
be like a pretty big cyclist i don't do
it much anymore just because of kids and
like prioritizing other things right
but one of the most important things to
learn as a cyclist is to take a rest day
but to me and to cyclists like resting
is a function of optimizing for the long
run
it's not like a thing that you do for
its own merits
it's actually like if you don't rest
your muscles don't recover and then
you're just not as like you're not
training as efficiently you should
probably the the successful people i've
known in terms of athletes they hate
rest days
but they know they have to do it for the
long term like absolutely they think
their opposition is getting stronger and
stronger and that's the feeling but you
know it's the right thing and usually
you need a coach to help you yeah
totally so i mean i use this thing
called training peaks and it's
interesting because it actually
mathematically shows like where you are
on the curve and all this stuff
yeah but you have to re like you have to
have that rest but it it's a function of
going harder for longer again it's this
reinforcement learning like planning the
aggregate and long but a lot of people
will hide behind laziness by saying that
they're trying to optimize for the long
run and they're not they're just not
working very hard but again you don't
have to sign up for it it's totally cool
like i don't think less of people for
like not working super hard just like
don't sign up for things that require
working super hard and some of that
requires for the leadership to have the
guts the boldness to communicate
effectively at the very beginning i mean
sometimes i think
most of the problems arise from the fact
that the
leadership is kind of hesitant
to to communicate this the socially
um difficult
truth of what it takes to be
at this company so they kind of
say hey come come with us there's we
have snacks you know
but unlimited vacation and yeah you know
uh ray at bridgewater is always
fascinating because you know people
it's been called like a cult on the
outside or cultish and
but what's fascinating is like they just
don't give on their principles they're
like listen this is what it's like to
work here we record every meeting
we're like brutally honest
and that's not gonna feel right to
everyone and if it doesn't feel regular
totally cool
just go work somewhere else but if you
work here you are signing up for this
and that's that's been fascinating to me
because it's honesty up front it's a
system in which you
operate
um and if it's not for you like no one's
forcing you to work there right
i i actually did so i i did a
conversation with him and uh
kind of got stuck in a funny moment
which is uh
at the end i asked him you know to give
me honest feedback of how i did on the
interview
and um
i don't think so he was super nice
he asked me
he's like well tell me did you
accomplish what you were hoping to
accomplish i was like that's not that's
not
i'm asking you as an objective observer
of two people talking how do we do today
and then he's like well um he gave me
this politician answer well i feel like
we've accomplished successful
communication of like ideas which is i'd
like i've loved to spread some of the
ideas
in that like in principles and so on
back to my original point it's really
hard to get even for ray
it's really hard to give feedback
and one of the other things i learned
from him and and
just people in that world is like
man humans really like to pretend like
they've come to
uh
that they've come to some kind of
meeting of the minds like if there's
conflict if you and i have conflict
it's always better to meet face to face
right we're on the phone slack is not
great right email's not great but face
to face what's crazy is you and i get
together and we actively try to even if
we're not actually solving the conflict
we actively try to paper over the
conflict oh yeah it didn't really bother
bothering me that much oh yeah i'm sure
you didn't mean it i'm sure but like
no in our minds we're still there yeah
um so this is one of the things that as
a leader you always have to be digging
especially as you straight to the
conflict yeah but as you ascend no one
wants to tell you you're crazy no one
wants to tell you your idea is bad
and you can you're like oh oh i'm going
to be a leader and the idea is well i'm
just going to ask people no one tells
you
so like you have to look for the markers
knowing that literally just people
aren't going to tell you along the way
and be paranoid i mean you asked about
selling you know the company i think one
of the biggest differences between me
and a lot of other entrepreneurs is like
i wasn't completely confident we could
do it like we could be
alone and and
and actually be great and if any
entrepreneur is honest with you they
also feel that way but a lot of people
are like well i have to be cocky and
just say
i can do this on my own we're going to
be fine we're going to crush everyone
some people do say that and then it's
not right and they and they fail
but um
being honest in that moment
with yourself with the those close to
you and also uh you talked about the
personality of leaders and and who
resonates and who doesn't
it's rare that i see
leaders be vulnerable
rare
and
one thing i tried to do at instagram at
least internally
was like say when i screwed up
and like point out how i was wrong about
things and point out where my judgment
was off
everyone thinks they have to bat a
thousand
right like
that's crazy the best quant hedge funds
in the world bat
50.001 percent they just take a lot of
bets right renaissance
they might they might bat fifty one
percent right but
holy hell like the question isn't are
you right every single time and you have
to seem invincible
the question is how many at-bats do you
get and on average are you are you
better on average
right
with enough bets and enough at bats that
your aggregate can be very high
i mean steve jobs was wrong at a lot of
stuff
the newton was too early right next not
quite right
um there was even a time when he said
like no one will ever want to watch
video
on the ipod
totally wrong
but who cares if you come around and
realize your mistake and fix it
it becomes just like you said harder and
harder when your ego grows and the
number of people around you that say
positive things towards you
grows and i actually think it's really
valuable that
like let's manage and a counter factual
where instagram became worth like 300
billion or something crazy right
um
i kind of like that my life is
relatively normal now when i say
relatively you get what i mean i'm not
making a claim that i live a normal life
but like i certainly don't live in a
world where there are like 15 sherpas
following me like fetching me water or
whatever like that's not how it works i
actually like that i
have a sense of humility of like i may
not found another thing that's nearly as
big so i have to work twice as hard
or i have to like learn twice as much i
have to re
my we haven't talked about machine
learning yet but my favorite thing is
all these like famous
you know uh tech guys who have worked in
the industry pontificating about the
future of machine learning and how it's
gonna kill us all and right like
and like i'm pretty sure they've never
tried to build anything with machine
learning themselves yes
so there's a nice line between people
that actually built stuff with the
machine like actually program something
or at least understand some of those
fundamentals and the people they're just
saying philosophical stuff for
journalists and so on it's it's a it's
an interesting line to walk because the
people who program
are often not philosophers
or don't have the attention they can't
write an op-ed for the wall street
journal like it doesn't work so like
it's nice to be both a little bit like
to have elements of both my point is the
fact that i have to learn stuff from
scratch or or that i choose to are like
it's humbling uh
yeah i mean again
i have a lot of advantages i like
but my point is it's awesome to be
back in a game where you have to fight
that is that's fun so being humble being
vulnerable
it's an important aspect of leader and i
hope it serves me well but like i can't
fast forward 10 years to now i'm just
that's my game plan
before i forget i have to ask you one
last thing on instagram
what do you think about the
whistleblower francis
hogan recently coming out and saying
that facebook is aware for instagram's
harmful effect on teenage girls
as per their own internal research
studies and the matter what do you think
about this
baby of yours instagram being under fire
now as we've been talking about
under the leadership of facebook
you know i often question
where does the blame lie
is the blame at the people
that originated the network me
right
uh is the blame
at like the decision to combine the
network with
another network with a certain set of
values
is the blame
at how it gets run after i left like is
is it the driver or is it the car
right
um
is it that someone enabled these devices
in the first place if you go to an
extreme right
or is it the
users themselves just human nature is it
is it just the way of human nature sure
and like the idea that we're gonna find
a mutually exclusive answer here is
crazy there's not one place it's a
combination of a lot of these things
and then the question is like is it true
at all right like i'm not actually
saying that's not true or that it's true
but
there's always more nuance here
do i believe that social media has an
effect on young people well it's got it
they use it a lot
and i bet you there are a lot of
positive effects and i bet you there are
negative effects just like any
technology
and where i've come to in my thinking on
this is that i think any technology has
negative side effects the question is as
a leader what do you do about them and
are you actively working on them or do
you just like not really believe in them
if you're a leader that sits there and
says well we're going to put an enormous
amount of resources against this we're
going to acknowledge when there are
true criticisms we're going to be
vulnerable that we're not perfect
and we're going to go fix them and we're
going to be held accountable along the
way
i think that people generally really
respect that
but i think that where facebook i think
has had issues in the past is where they
say things like i can't remember what
mark said about misinformation during
the election there was that like famous
quote where he's like
it's pretty crazy to think that facebook
had anything to do with this election
like that was something like that quote
and i don't remember what stage he was
on and yeah yeah
but ooh that did not age well right like
you have to be willing to say well maybe
there's there's there's something there
and and wow like i want to go look into
it and truly believe it in your gut but
if people look at you and how you act
and what you say and don't believe
you truly feel that way
it's not just the words you say about
how you say them and that people believe
that you actually feel the pain of
having caused any suffering so to me
it's um it's much more about your
actions
and your posture post event than it is
about debugging the why because i don't
know is it
like i don't know this research it was
written well after i left right like
is it the algorithm is it the explorer
page is it the people you might know
unit connecting you to you know ideas
that are dangerous like i i really don't
know yeah um
so we'd have to have a much deeper
i think dive to understand where the
blame lies what's very unpleasant to me
to consider now i don't know if this is
true but to consider the very fact that
there might be some complicated games
being played here for example you know
as somebody i really love psychology
and
i love it enough to know that the field
is pretty broken in the following way
it's very difficult to study human
beings well at scale because the
questions you ask affect the results you
can you can basically get any results
you want and so you have an internal
facebook study that asks some question
of which we don't know the full details
there's some kind of analysis
but that's just the one little tiny
slice into a some much bigger picture
and so you can have
thousands of employees of facebook one
of them comes out and picks whatever
narrative knowing that they become
famous coupled with the other really
uncomfortable thing i see in the world
which is journalists seem to understand
they get a lot of click-bait attention
from saying something negative about
social networks certain companies like
they even get some
some click-bait stuff
about tesla or about
especially when it's like when there's a
public famous ceo type of person if they
get a lot of views on the negative not
the positive the positive they'll get i
mean it actually goes to the thing you
were saying before if there's a hot sexy
new product
that's great to look forward to they get
positive on that but absent the product
it's nice to have
uh like the ceo messing up with some
kind of way and so
couple that with the whistleblower and
with the
uh
this whole dynamic of journalism and so
on you know uh with social dilemma being
a really popular documentary it's like
all right
my concern is there's deep
flaws in human nature here in terms of
things we need to deal with like the
nature of hate yeah of bullying all
those kinds of things and then there's
people who are trying to use that
potentially to become famous and make
money off of
off of blaming others for causing more
of the problem as opposed to helping
solve the problem so i don't know what
to think i'm not saying this is like i'm
just uncomfortable with i guess not
knowing what to think about any of this
because a bunch of folks i know that
work at facebook
on the machine learning side so young
lacoon i mean they they're quite upset
by what's happening because there's a
lot of really brilliant good people
inside facebook they're trying to yeah
do good and so like all of us impressed
jan is one of them and he has an amazing
team of the machine learning researchers
like
he's really upset with the fact that
people don't seem to understand
that this this is not the portrayal does
not represent the the full nature of
efforts that's going on facebook so i
don't know what to think about that well
you just i think
very helpfully explained the nuance of
the situation and why it's so hard to
understand
but a couple things one is um
i think i i have been surprised at
the scale with which
some
product manager
can do an enormous amount of harm to a
very very large company
by releasing a trove of documents like i
i think i read a couple of them when
they got published i haven't even spent
any time going deep part of it's like i
don't really feel like reliving a
previous life but um
wow
like talk about
challenging the idea of open culture and
like what that does to facebook
internally if facebook was built like i
remember um
like my office
uh
we had this like no visitors rule around
my office because we always had like
confidential stuff up on the walls and
never was super angry because they're
like that goes against our culture of
transparency and like mark's in the fish
cube or whatever they call it the
aquarium i think they called it um where
like literally anyone could see what he
was doing at any point and
um
and i don't know i mean other companies
like apple have been
quiet slash lockdown snapchats the same
way for
a reason and
i don't know what this does to
transparency on the inside of startups
that value that i think that it's a
seminal moment
and you can say well you should have
nothing to hide right but to your point
you can pick out documents that show
anything right
um but i don't know so
what happens to transparency inside of
startups and the culture that
will have
that that startups or companies in the
future will grow like the startup of the
future that becomes the next facebook
will be locked down and what does that
do
right so that's part one part two
like i i don't think that you could
design
a more like
uh uh
well-orchestrated
handful of events from the like 16
minutes to
um releasing the documents in the way
that they were released at the right
time
that takes a lot of planning and
partnership and it seems like she has a
partner at some firm right that probably
uh helped a lot with this but
man as at a personal level if you're her
you'd have to really believe in what you
are doing
really believe in it because you are
personally putting your ass on the line
right like you've got a
very large company
that that doesn't like enemies right um
it takes a lot of guts
uh and
i don't love these conspiracy theories
about like oh she's being financed from
some person or people like i don't love
them because that's like the easy thing
to say
i think the the the occam's razor here
is like someone thought they were doing
something wrong
and was like very very courageous in in
i don't know if courageous is the word
but like so
without getting into like is she a
martyr is she courageous is she right
like let's put that aside for a second
yeah
then there are the documents themselves
they say what they say
to your point
a lot of the things that like people
have been worried about
already in the documents are or they're
already been said externally and
um
i don't know i'm just like i'm i'm
thankful that i am focused on new things
with my life
well let me just say i just think it's a
really hard problem that probably
facebook and twitter are trying to solve
i'm actually just fascinated by how hard
this problem is there are fundamental
issues at facebook in tone and in an
approach of how product gets built and
the objective functions and
um
and since people uh uh organizations are
not people so yawn and fair right like
there are a lot of really great people
who like literally just want to push
reinforcement learning forward they
literally just want to teach a robot to
touch feel lift right like
they're not thinking about political
misinformation right yeah but there's a
there's a strong connection between what
funds that research and an enormously
profitable machine
uh that has trade-offs and
uh one cannot
one cannot separate the two you are not
completely separate from the system
so
i agree it can feel really frustrating
to feel if you're internally internal
there that you're working on something
completely unrelated and you feel like
your group's good i can understand that
but there's some responsibility still
you have to acknowledge it's like the
ray dalio thing you have to look in the
mirror and see if there's problems and
you have to fix those problems
you mentioned machine learning
reinforcement quite a bit i mean to me
social networks is one of the exciting
places
recommender systems where machine
learning is applied where else in the
world
in space of possibilities over the next
5 10 20 years do you think we're going
to see impact of machine learning
when you try on the philosophical level
on a technical level what do you think
or or within social networks themselves
well i think the obvious answers are
climate change right like think about
how much fuel
or or just waste there is in energy
consumption
today because
we don't plan accordingly because we
take the least efficient route or the
logistics and stuff the supply chain all
that kind of stuff yeah i mean
listen if we're going to fight climate
change like
one really way
one awesome way to do it is figure out
how to optimize how we operate as a
species and
and minimize the amount of energy we
consume to maximize whatever economic
impact we want to have
because right now those two are very
much tied together and
i don't believe that has to be the case
there's this really interesting you've
read it um
for people who are listening there's
this really interesting paper on
reinforcement learning and energy
consumption inside buildings it's like
one of the seminal ones right um but
imagine that at massive scale that's
super interesting i mean they've done
like resource planning for servers for
peak load using reinforcement learning i
don't know if that was at google or
somewhere else but like okay great you
do it for servers but what if you could
do it for just capacity and general
energy capacity for cities and planning
for traffic and of course there's all
the um self-driving cars and
i don't know like i'm not going to
pontificate like crazy ideas
using reinforcement learning or machine
learning it's just so clear to me that
humans don't think quickly enough so
it's interesting to think about machine
learning
helping a little bit
at scale so a little bit to a large
number of people that has a huge impact
so if you optimize
say google maps something like that
trajectory planning or would it map
quest first
uh yeah getting here i looked and it was
like here's the most energy efficient
route i was like i'm gonna be late i
need to take the fastest route as
opposed to unrolling the map yeah yeah
like and that's going to be very
inefficient no matter what i was
definitely the other day like part of
the epsilon of epsilon greedy with waze
where like i was sent on like a weird
route that i could tell they're like we
just need to collect data of this road
like we just kevin's the ant they sent
out kevin's definitely gonna be the
guinea pig and great now we have did you
at least feel pride oh going through it
i was like oh this is fun like now they
get data about this weird shortcut and
actually i hit all the green lights and
it worked and i'm like this is a problem
data bad data they're just going to
imagine i could see you slowing down and
stopping in a green light just to give
them the right kind of data yeah
um but to answer your question like i
feel like that was fairly unsatisfying
and it's easy to say climate change but
what i would say is
at instagram everything we applied
machining learning to uh got better for
users and it got better better for the
company i saw the power i didn't fully
understand it as an executive and i
think that's actually one of the issues
that uh
and when i say understand i mean the
mathematics of it like i understand what
it does i understand that it helps
but um there are a lot of executives now
that
talk about it and the way that they talk
about the internet or they talked about
the internet like 10 years ago they're
like we're gonna build mobile and you're
like what does that mean they're like
we're just gonna do mobile and you're
like okay
um so my sense is the next generation of
leaders will have grown up having had
classes
in reinforcement learning supervised
learning whatever
and they will be able to thoughtfully
apply it to their companies and the
places it it is needed most
and that's really cool because i mean
talk about efficiency gains
i it's
that that's what excites me the most
about it yeah so there's it's
interesting just to get a fundamental
first principles understanding of
certain concepts of machine learning so
supervised learning from an executive
perspective supervised learning you have
to have a lot of humans label a lot of
data so the question there is okay can
we gather
a large amount of data that can be
labeled well
and that's the question tesla asks like
can we create a data engine that keeps
um
sending an imperfect machine learning
system out there whenever it fails it
gives us data back we label it by human
and we send it back and forth so this
way then there is uh yamaha coons
excited about this self-supervised
learning where
you do much less human labeling and
there's some kind of mechanism for the
system to learn it by itself on the on
the human generated data and then
there's the reinforcement learning which
is like
basically allowing it's it's applying
the alpha zero uh technology that uh
allowed through self-play
to learn how to solve the game of go and
and
achieve incredible levels at the game of
chess
it can you formulate the problem you're
trying to solve in a way that's amenable
to reinforcement learning and can you
get the right kind of signal at scale
because you need a lot a lot of signal
and that that's that's kind of
fascinating to see which part of a
social network can you convert into a
reinforcement learning problem the
fascinating thing about reinforcement
learning i think
is that we now have learned to apply
uh neural networks to guess
uh
you know q func like the q function
basically the values for any state in
action
and that is fascinating because we used
to just like i don't know have like a
linear regression like hope it worked
and that was the fanciest version of it
but now you look at it i'm like trying
to learn this stuff and i look at it i'm
like there are like 17 different
acronyms of different ways you can try
to apply this no one quite agrees like
what's the best generally if you're
trying to like build a neural network
they're pretty well-trodden ways of
doing that
you use atom you use relu you use like
there's just like general good ideas and
in in reinforcement learning i feel like
the consensus is like it totally depends
and by the way it's really hard to get
it to converge and it's noisy and it
like
so there are all these really
interesting ideas around building
simulators um
you know like for instance in
self-driving right like you
don't want to like actually have someone
get in an accident to learn that an
accident is bad so you start simulating
accidents simulating aggressive drivers
they're simulating crazy dogs that run
into the street and
wow fascinating right like that my mind
starts racing and then the question is
okay forget about uh self-driving cars
let's talk about uh social networks
um how can you produce a better more
thoughtful experience using these types
of of algorithms and
honestly in talking to some of the
people that work at facebook and and old
instagramers
most people are like yeah we tried a lot
of things didn't quite ever make it work
i mean for the longest time facebook ads
was effectively a logistic regression
okay i don't know what it is now but
like if you look at this paper they
published back in the day it was
literally just a logistic regression
made a lot of money um
so even at these like extremely large
scales if we are not yet touching what
reinforcement learning can truly do
imagine what the next 10 years looks
like yeah how cool is that it's amazing
so i really like the use of
reinforcement learning as part of the
simulation for example
like with self-driving cars it's
modeling pedestrians so the nice thing
about reinforcement learning
it can be used to
learn agents within the world
so they can learn to behave properly
like you can teach pedestrians to
like you don't hard code the way they
behave they learn how to behave in that
same way i do have a hope was it jack
dorsey talks about healthy conversations
you talked about uh meaningful
interactions i believe yeah
like
simulating interactions
so you can learn how to manage that it's
fascinating so where most of your
algorithm development happens on in
virtual worlds
and then you can really learn how to
design the interface how you design much
of aspects of the experience
in terms of the how you select what's
shown in the feed all those kinds of
things that
it feels like if you can connect
reinforce some learning to that that's
super exciting yep and uh
i think if you have if you have a
company and leadership that believe in
doing the right things and can apply
this technology in the right way some
really special stuff can happen
it is mostly like
likely going to be a group of people
we've never heard about startup from
scratch
right um
and and you asked if like new social
networks could be built i
i've got to imagine they will be and
whoever starts it it might be some kids
in a garage that took these classes from
these people you right like
and they're building
all of these things with this tech at
the core so i'm trying not to be someone
who just like throws around
reinforcement learning as a buzzword i
truly believe that it is
the most cutting edge
in what can happen in social networks
and i also believe it's super hard
like it's super hard to make it work
it's super hard to do it at scale it's
super hard to find people that truly
understand it
so i'm not gonna say that like
i think it'll be applied in social
networks before we have true
self-driving
yeah
let me put it that way we could argue
about this for a long time but yes i
agree with you so i think self-driving
is way harder than people realize oh
absolutely uh let me ask you in terms of
that kid in the garage or those couple
of kids in the garage what advice would
you give to them if they want to start a
new social network or
a business what advice would you give to
somebody with a big dream and a young
startup
to me you have to choose to do something
that even if it fails like you you it
was so fun right like
we never started instagram knowing it
was going to be big we started instagram
because we loved photography we loved
social networks i had seen what other
social networks had done and i thought
hmm maybe we did a spin on this but like
nowhere was our feet predestined like it
wasn't like
it wasn't written out anywhere that
everything was going to go great and i
often think the counterfactual like what
if it had not gone well i would've been
like i don't know that was fun we raised
some money we learned some stuff and
and does it position you well for the
next experience
that's the advice that i would give to
anyone wanting to start something today
which is like
does this meet with your ultimate goals
not wealth not fame none of that because
all of that by the way is like
you can get super famous and super
wealthy and
i like i think generally those are not
things that
again it's easy to say with like a lot
of money that somehow like it's not good
to have a lot of money it's just
i think that complicates life enormously
in a way that people don't fully
comprehend so i think it's way more
interesting to shoot for can i make
something that people love
that provides value in the world that i
love building that i love working on
that i write that's um
that's what i would do if i were
starting from scratch and by the way
like in some ways that i will do that
personally which is like choose the
thing that you get up every morning
you're like i
love this
even when it's painful
even when it's painful what about a
social network specifically if you were
to imagine
put yourself in the mind of someone
compete against myself i can't give out
ideas okay i gotcha
no but it's like high level you like
focus on community yeah
and yeah
i i said that as a as a half joke um in
all honesty i think these things are so
hard to build that like ideas are a dime
a dozen but um
you have to i talked about keeping it
simple
can i tell you which is a liberating
idea that model is yes it's three
circles and they overlap one circle is
uh what do i have experience at slash
what am i good at i don't like saying
what am i good at because it just like
seems like
what do i have experience in right what
can i bring to the table what am i
excited about is the other circle what
gets what's just super cool right that i
want to work on because even when this
is hard
um
i think it's so cool i want to stick
with it
and the last circle is like what does
the world need
and if that circle ain't there it
doesn't matter what you work on because
there are a lot of startups that exist
that just no one needs
or very small markets need
but if you want to be successful i think
if you're like if you're good at it you
have it sorry if you're good at it if
you're passionate about it and the world
needs it i mean this sounds simple but
not enough people sit down and just
think about those circles and think
do these things overlapping can i get
that middle section it's small but can i
get that middle section
um i think a lot about that personally
and then you have to be really honest
about the circle that you're good at
and really honest about the circle
that uh the world needs
and i suppose really honest about the
passion like what you actually love yeah
as opposed to like some kind of dream of
making money all those kind of stuff
like literally love i had a former
engineer who decided to start a startup
and i was like are you sure you want to
start a company versus like join
something else
because um
being a coach of an nba team and playing
basketball are two very very different
things
and like not everyone fully understands
the difference
i think you can kind of do it both
um
and i don't know jury's out on that one
because like they're in the middle of it
now so but it's really important to
figure out what you're good at not be
full of yourself like truly look at your
track record
um what's the saying like it ain't
bragging if you could if if you can do
it um
but too many people
are delusional and like think they're
better at things than they actually are
or think there's a bigger market than
there actually is just
when you confuse your passion for things
with a big market that's really scary
right like just because you think it's
cool doesn't mean that it's a big
business opportunity so like what
evidence do you have again i'm a fairly
like i'm a strict rationalist on this
and like sometimes people don't like
working with me because i'm pretty
pragmatic about things like i'm not
i'm not elon like i don't sit and make
bold proclamations about visiting mars
like that's just not how i work
i'm like okay i want to build this
really cool thing that's fairly
practical and i think we could do it and
it's in this way and what's cool though
is like that's just my sweet spot i'm
not like
i just i can't i can't with a straight
face talk about the metaverse i can't i
just it's not me
uh what do you think about the the
facebook renaming it
and that is a dick i just literally know
like i'm i'm fairly
i like to live in the next five years
and like what what things can i get out
in a year that people will use at scale
and
um
so it's just again those circles i think
are different for different people but
it's important to realize that like
market matters you being good at it
matters and having passion for it
matters uh your question sorry
well unless
on this topic in terms of funding
is there
by way of advice
was funding in your own journey helpful
unhelpful
like is there a right time to get
funding for funding venture funding or
anything borrow some money from your
parents i don't know
like is money get in the way does it
help is the timing important is there
some kind of wisdom you can
give there because you were
exceptionally successful very quickly
funding helps as long as it's from the
right people
that includes yourself and i'll talk
about myself funding myself in in a
second which is like because i can fund
myself doing whatever projects i can do
i don't really have another person
putting pressure on me except for myself
and that creates
strange dynamics right but let's like
talk about people getting funding from a
venture capitalist initially
uh we raised money from matt kohler at
benchmark he's brilliant
amazing guy very thoughtful
and he was very helpful early on but i
have stories from entrepreneurs where
they raise money from the wrong person
or the wrong firm where incentives
weren't aligned
they didn't think in the same way
um
and bad things happened because of that
the border room was always noisy
there were fights like we just never had
that matt was great
i think usu like capital these days is
kind of a dime a dozen right like as
long as you're fundable like it seems
like there's money out there this is
what i'm hearing
um
it's really important that you are
aligned and that you think of raising
money as hiring someone for your team
rather than taking money
if capital is plentiful right
it provides a certain amount of pressure
to do the right thing that i think is
healthy for any startup and it keeps you
real and honest because they don't want
to lose their money they're paid to not
lose their money
the problem you know
maybe i could de-personalize it but like
i remember having lunch with elon it's
only happened once
and i asked him
like i was trying to figure out what i
was doing after instagram right
and i asked him something about like
angel investing and he looked at me with
a straight face and was like why the f
would i do that like why like i was like
i don't know like you're connected like
seems like he's like i only invested
myself i was like
okay you know like not the confidence i
was just like what a novel idea it's
like
yeah if you have money like why not just
put it against your bag and like yeah
enable
you
visiting mars or something right like
that's awesome great but i had never
really thought of it that way
but also with that comes an interesting
dynamic where
um
you don't actually have
people who are gonna lose that money
telling you hey don't do this or hey you
need to face this reality so you need to
create other versions
of that truth teller
and i
whatever i do next that's going to be
one of the interesting challenges is how
do you create that truth-telling
situation um and that's part of why by
the way i think someone like jack when
you start square you have money but you
still
you bring on partners because i think it
creates
a truth-telling type environment um i'm
still trying to figure this out like i
like
it's an interesting
it's an interesting diamond so you're
thinking of
perhaps launching some kind of venture
where you're investing in yourself
i mean
is there in the books potentially i'm 37
going on 38 next month i have a long
life to live i'm not definitely not
gonna sit on the beach right
so
i'm gonna do something at some point and
i gotta imagine i will i will like help
fund it right so the other way of
thinking about this is you could park
your money in the smp and this is bad
because the smp has done wonderfully
well in the last year right
or you can invest in yourself and um
if you're not going to invest in
yourself you probably shouldn't do a
startup it's kind of the way of thinking
about it
and you can invest in yourself in the
way elon does which is basically uh go
all in on this investment maybe that's
one way to achieve accountability is
like you're kind of screwed if you're if
you fail
yeah that's
yeah i i personally like that i like
burning bridges behind me so that i'm
if it fails
yeah yeah yeah
it's really important though
one of the things i think mark said to
me early on
that that sticks with me that i think is
true uh we were talking about people who
had left like operating roles and
started doing venture or something it
was like a lot of people convinced
themselves they work really hard like
they think they work really hard and
they they put on the show and in their
minds they work really hard but they
don't work very hard
there is something about lighting a fire
underneath you and burning bridges such
that you can't turn back yeah that i
think
you know we didn't talk about this
specifically but i think you're right
there is
you need to have that because there's
this self-delusion at a certain scale
oh i have so many board calls oh like we
have all these things to figure out it's
like
[Music]
this is one of the hard parts about it
being an operator is like
there are so many people that have made
a lot of money not operating
but operating is just one of the hardest
things on earth it is just so effing
hard
it is stressful it is you're dealing
with real humans you're not just like
throwing capital in and hoping it grows
i'm not undermining the vc mindset i
think it's a wonderful thing and needed
and and so many wonderful vcs i've
worked with
but um
yeah like when your ass is on the line
and it's your money it's
talk to me in 10 years we'll see how it
goes
yeah but like you're saying that is a
source when you wake up in the morning
as uh
you look forward to the day full of
challenges that's also where you can
find happiness let me ask you about love
and friendship sure what's the role
in this heck of a difficult journey
you've been on
of love
of uh friendship what's the role of love
in the human condition
well first things first the woman i
married my wife nicole
no way i could do what i do
if we weren't together she had the
filter idea yeah yeah exactly we didn't
go over that story
um
everything is a partnership right and
to achieve great things it's not about
like someone pulling their weight in
places like it's not like someone's
supporting you
so that you could do this other thing
it's literally like
you know i mike and i and our
partnership
as co-founders
is fascinating because i don't think
instagram would have happened without
that partnership like
either him or me alone no way
we pushed and pulled each other in a way
that
allowed us to build a better thing
because of it
nicole sure like she pushed me to work
on the filters early on and yes that's
exciting it's a fun story right
but the truth of it is
being able to like level with someone
about how hard the process is and have
someone see you for who you are before
instagram
and know that there's a constant you
throughout all of this
and be able to call you when you're
drifting from that
but also support you when you're trying
to stick with that that's
i mean that's that's true
friendship slash love whatever you want
to call it um
but also for someone not to care i
remember nicole saying hey like i know
you're gonna do this instagram thing you
should
i guess it was bourbon at the time you
should do it because um
you know even if it doesn't work we can
move to like a smaller apartment and
it'll be fine like we'll make it work
how beautiful is that right yeah that's
almost like a superpower it gives you
permission to fail and somehow that
actually leads to success but also she's
like the least impressed about instagram
of anyone she's like yeah it's great but
like i love you for you like i like that
you're like a decent beautiful
it's beautiful
with the uh with the gantt chart and
thanksgiving which i still think is a
brilliant effing idea thank you um big
ridiculous question
have you uh
you're you're old and wise at this stage
so have you discovered meaning to this
whole thing why the hell are we
descendants of um
apes here on earth what's the meaning of
it what's the meaning of life i haven't
and it and i i am inco so the crazy so
the best learning
for me has been like no matter what
level of success you achieve
you're still worried about similar
things maybe on a slightly different
scale you're still
concerned about the same thing you're
still self-conscious about the same
things it's like
and
actually that moment going through that
is what makes you believe there's got to
be like more machinery to life or
purpose to life and that that we're all
chasing these materialistic things but
you start
start realizing like um it's almost like
you know the truman show when he gets
the edge and he like knocks against it
he's like what like there's this
awakening that happens when you get to
that edge that you realize oh
like sure it's great it's great that we
all chase money and fame and and success
but you hit the edge and and i'm not
even claiming i hit an edge like like
elon's hit an edge like there's clearly
larger scales
but what's cool is you learn that like
it doesn't actually matter and that
there are all these other things that
truly matter
um that's not a case for working less
hard that's not a case for taking it
easy that's not a case for the four day
work week
what that is a case for is designing
your life exactly the way you want to
design it because
i don't know i i think we go around the
or you know the sun a certain number of
times and then we die and then that's it
that's me are you afraid of that moment
no not at all in fact
at least not yet
listen i'm like a pilot like i do
crazy things and i like
um no i like if anything i'm like oh
i gotta choose uh uh mindfully and
purposefully the thing i am doing right
now
and not just fall into it because you're
gonna wake up one day and ask yourself
why the hell you spent the last 10 years
doing x y or z yeah so i guess
my like shorter answer to this is
doing things on purpose
because you choose to do them
so important in life
and not just like floating down the
river of life hitting branches along the
way because you will hit branches right
but rather like literally plotting a
course and not having a 10-year plan but
just choosing every day to opt in
that i think has been more
like i haven't figured out the meaning
of life by any stretch of the
imagination but it certainly isn't money
and it certainly isn't fame and it
certainly isn't travel and it's like and
it's way more of like opting into the
game you love playing
every day opting in just opting in and
like it's don't let it happen you opt in
kevin uh it's great to end on the
love
and the meaning of life this is an
amazing conversation a lot of fun thank
you you gave me like a light into some
fascinating aspects of this of the
technical world and i can't honestly
wait
to see what you do next thank you so
much thanks for having me
thanks for listening to this
conversation with kevin systrom
to support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from kevin systrom himself
focusing on one thing
and doing it really really well can get
you very far
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you